Hi, Josh, Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什、克雷格和亚历克。
My name is Lisa.
我叫丽莎。
I'm 24 from Austria and I just wrapped up traveling through Australia for six months by myself, which was quite the rollercoaster.
我24岁，来自奥地利，我刚刚独自完成了为期六个月的澳大利亚之旅，这真是一段跌宕起伏的经历。
I've always looked at your show as a comfort show and during my travels, I found the rewatch podcast and I got to be honest, I might have binged every single episode in an embarrassingly short amount of time and I might have already listened to a bunch of it twice as well.
我一直把你们的节目当作治愈系节目，在我的旅行途中，我发现了这个重温播客，老实说，我可能在令人尴尬的极短时间内刷完了每一集，而且我可能已经把很多集听了整整两遍。
So you guys have spent countless hours of driving through Australia with me.
所以你们在不知不觉中陪着我度过了在澳大利亚驾驶的无数个小时。
I love how you dissect the episodes and as someone who is fascinated by filmmaking.
我喜欢你们剖析剧集的方式，作为一个对电影制作着迷的人。
I love all the behind the scenes, details and how you shot certain things.
我很喜欢所有的幕后细节以及你们是如何拍摄某些镜头的。
I'm not the most mentally stable person as well, so whenever I didn't want to hear my own thoughts, I found great comfort in listening to yours.
我的精神状态也不是特别稳定，所以每当我不想听见自己的胡思乱想时，听听你们的声音总能带给我巨大的慰藉。
I started to admit my interest in acting to myself doing my travels.
在旅行期间，我开始向自己承认我对表演的兴趣。
I currently study electrical engineering, so we'll see if I ever have to courage to pursue that dream.
我目前正在学习电气工程，所以我们走着瞧吧，看我以后有没有勇气去追求那个梦想。
Well anyways, thank you for everything you do.
无论如何，谢谢你们所做的一切。
I'm looking forward to all of the episodes to come.
我很期待接下来的每一集。
I'm alone.
我独自一人。
Don't be super book city.
别太装腔作势了。
When I see, please permit me to tell you everything.
当我看到时，请允许我把一切都告诉你。
Craig, how about that?
克雷格，觉得怎么样？
We were keeping an Austrian woman company on her six-month trip through Australia.
我们在她为期六个月的澳大利亚之行中，一直陪伴着一位奥地利女性。
I mean, I feel like we were there with her or we were there with her, we got all the benefits of that trip.
我的意思是，我觉得我们就跟她在一起，或者说我们当时就在她身边，我们享受了那次旅行的所有好处。
We got all the benefits.
我们享受了所有的好处。
We were somehow there with her.
我们不知怎么的就和她在一起。
I love it, I fucking love it.
我喜欢，我他妈太喜欢了。
Hemium has traveled the world.
老爸粉已经走遍了世界。
Now this podcast is traveling the world.
现在这个播客也在走向世界。
There's something very, very cool about the energy of that.
这种能量中有一种非常非常酷的东西。
And speaking of energy, this is our second, I'm gonna be just, I'm gonna pull back the curtain.
说到能量，这是我们的第二场，我直说吧，我要揭开幕布了。
This is our second record of the night.
这是我们今晚录制的第二场。
We're doing these at night, Josh is a little baby and we're doing it at night once the baby's asleep.
我们是在晚上录制的，乔什像个小宝宝，我们在宝宝睡着后的晚上开录。
And there's our second one and we're like a little, we're like, all right, we gotta get energy up.
这是我们的第二场，我们就像，好吧，我们得把状态调动起来。
The second I hear a story like that, the second Alec hits play and it's this message that Josh and I have never heard, and it's a Hymn fan and a Hymn fan saying, you were in Australia with me?
我一听到这样的故事，亚历克一按下播放键，听到这条乔什和我从未听过的留言，得知这是一个老爸粉，而且是一个老爸粉说“你们当时和我一起在澳大利亚？”
I instantly have energy again.
我瞬间又来了精神。
I also love that now that people aren't just binging the show.
我也喜欢现在人们不只是疯狂补剧。
Now they're binging the podcast about going back over episodes, it's great.
现在他们还在疯狂收听回顾剧集的播客，这太棒了。
It's a real honor to us.
这对我们来说是真正的荣誉。
That's the best part of it.
这是最棒的部分。
Going to Australia with you is the best part of it.
和你一起去澳大利亚是最棒的部分。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
I feel an infusion of some energy from that, just from that message.
我从那条留言中感受到了能量的注入。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Welcome to how we made your mother, I'm Josh Radner.
欢迎收听《老爸老妈浪漫史解密》，我是乔什·拉德纳。
This is Craig Thomas.
这位是克雷格·托马斯。
My dear friend, Alec Lev is with us.
我们亲爱的朋友亚历克·莱夫也和我们在一起。
Our intrepid producer.
我们无畏的制片人。
I don't even know what that means, but people always say our intrepid producer.
我甚至不知道那是什么意思，但人们总是说我们无畏的制片人。
You're intrepid.
你确实无畏。
You just played us an Austrian woman talking about Australia.
你刚刚给我们放了一个奥地利女性谈论澳大利亚的音频。
That's fucking intrepid of you.
你真他妈的无畏。
That was intrepid as all get out.
那可真是无畏至极。
Yeah.
是的。
So yes, as Craig mentioned, we are pulling a two for tonight, But I also just got back from five or six days in Mexico with my wife and our baby.
所以，正如克雷格所提到的，我们今晚要连录两场，不过我刚刚和妻子还有宝宝在墨西哥待了五六天回来。
We went to a dear friend's wedding.
我们去参加了一位挚友的婚礼。
This couple met the same weekend that Jordana and I met.
这对夫妇相识的那个周末，正好我和约尔达娜相识。
This is Jordana's best friend, Ellie and they met her now husband, Nima, the same weekend Jordana and I met.
这是约尔达娜最好的朋友埃莉，她和现在的丈夫尼玛相识的周末，正好是乔丹娜和我相识的周末。
And so we were there to celebrate them.
所以我们去那里庆祝他们的喜结连理。
And there was a morning where, I think, was it the morning of, no, this is the morning, the morning before the wedding.
有一天早上，我想，是婚礼当天早上吗？不，这是那个早上，婚礼前一天早上。
And I see this woman, I know Christina, and she's talking to someone.
我看到这个女人，我认识克里斯蒂娜，她正在和某人说话。
And this woman says, Josh, Brenda Shae from How I Met Your Mother.
这个女人说，乔什，这是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的布伦达·谢伊。
Brenda Shae, one of the writers on How I Met Your Mother who wrote classics such as The Slutty Pumpkin.
布伦达·谢伊，《老爸老妈浪漫史》的编剧之一，她曾创作过《穿南瓜装的荡妇》等经典剧集。
And today's episode, do we sit triple?
今天的剧集，我们是三集连拍吗？
Jovis the triple, yeah.
乔维斯是拍了三集，对。
was at this wedding for my friends.
当时就在我朋友的婚礼上。
She knew Nima back in San Francisco.
她以前在旧金山就认识尼玛。
Yeah.
是的。
It's really strange that that's who we were right about to record this episode and there she is in Mexico, which is so weird, it's very cool.
真的很奇怪，就在我们准备录制这一集的时候，她居然在墨西哥，这太奇怪了，也非常酷。
Yes, and yeah, and this is why I'm struggling a little bit.
是的，这也是为什么我状态有点吃力。
But you're asleep.
但你一直在睡觉。
No, yesterday was just a travel day for like a comically, like I told you guys about the stroller mishap and the delayed flights.
不，昨天只是个旅行日，简直滑稽透顶，就像我跟你们说过婴儿车的糟心事和延误的航班一样。
And when you have a six month old, that stuff takes a toll.
当你有一个六个月大的宝宝时，那些事情真的很折腾人。
But it's like, he has an excuse, he's a baby.
但这就好比，他有借口，他还是个婴儿。
Like, what about us who are about to burst into tears?
那我们这些快要急哭了的人算怎么回事？
Like, it was tough, but we're happy to be home.
总之，过程虽然艰难，但很高兴能回家。
Respect to you and Jordana from going to Mexico for a destination wedding when you, you had such a good excuse in this young little baby boy to not go down.
向你和乔丹娜致敬，你们带着这么小的一个宝贝儿子，完全有很好的借口不去，却还是去墨西哥参加目的地婚礼。
This is like a, I think she had to go.
这就像是，我觉得她必须去。
She had to go.
她必须去。
And also her brother's getting married in Brazil.
而且她哥哥两周后也要在巴西结婚。
like in like two weeks, which we also can't miss.
大概两周后，那也是我们不能错过的。
So we're going to be doing another one of these.
所以我们还要再录一期这样的节目。
I know.
我知道。
I wonder what Hemium writer you'll meet then.
我在想到时候你会遇到哪个老爸老妈编剧。
Whoever we're going to talk about their episode next is going to be at that wedding.
接下来我们要聊到谁的剧集，谁就会出现在那场婚礼上。
That's really crazy.
这真的很疯狂。
Well, yes, Brenda Shea, we're a very good Hemium writer.
好吧，是的，布伦达·谢伊，我们非常优秀的老爸老妈编剧。
She's on all the first three seasons.
她参与了前三季的所有制作。
And she wrote today's episode and much respect to Brenda.
她写了今天的这一集，向布伦达致以崇高的敬意。
She's a very good writer.
她是一位非常优秀的编剧。
And she wrote them the Pixar movie Elemental, since that's Brenda had a very cool.
她还为皮克斯动画电影《疯狂元素城》写过剧本，因为布伦达真的很酷。
That's why she was in San Francisco and that's what she met Neema.
这就是为什么她在旧金山，也就是她遇到尼玛的地方。
Yeah, that's actually my, your friend.
是的，那其实是我的，你的朋友。
Yeah, so, and so, and speaking of which, Hemium, I have this little grid we made at one point.
是的，所以，说到这个，老爸老妈，我这儿有一个我们曾经制作过的小表格。
Hemium writers, Hemium writers have done some fucking cool things.
老爸老妈编剧，老爸老妈编剧们做过一些他妈的超酷的事情。
Can I do a little sidebar about this?
我能稍微扯开话题聊这个吗？
I'm gonna do a little sidebar, ready?
我要稍微扯开一下，准备好了吗？
Josh, you're tired, you take a brief nap during this.
乔什，你累了的话可以在这期间小睡一会儿。
I would have anyway, you didn't tell me.
我本来就会睡，你又没告诉我。
Whatever I get more than two sentences deep, I'm gonna leave now.
不管我讲超过两句话有多深，我现在就要走了。
Brenda Shea, elemental.
布伦达·谢伊，《疯狂元素城》。
We made this little grid of like amazing things Hemium writers, but these are other credits since I met your mother, the new Naked Gun movie, Dan Doug.
我们制作了这个小表格，上面列出了老爸老妈编剧们的惊人成就，这些都是他们离开《老爸老妈浪漫史》之后的其他作品，比如新《白头神探》电影，丹·达格。
They wrote that.
他们写了那个。
Chris and Phil, they just did Project Hail Mary.
克里斯和菲尔，他们刚刚完成了《生死J计划》。
I was at the premiere party for Project Hail Mary and ran into your friends who just got married at that premiere party because they're apparently everywhere.
我当时在《生死J计划》的首映派对上，在那场首映派对上刚好碰到了你们刚刚结婚的朋友，因为他们显然无处不在。
Everything about this is weirdly overlapping.
关于这一切的重合都显得诡异极了。
What else do we do?
我们还做了什么？
Glory, Collar, and Kelly created one day at a time, that reboot, just like, I'm just very proud of like the amazing work that like how I met your mother, writers have gone on to do it.
格洛里、科勒和凯利创作了《一个接一个》那个重启版，我真的为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的编剧们后来创作的出色作品感到非常自豪。
Dave Hemmingson wrote The Holdovers, got an Oscar nomination.
戴夫·海明森写了《留校察看》，还获得了奥斯卡提名。
He was just on with us a couple episodes ago, just like the coolest credits, Joe Kelly co-created Ted Lasso and Detroiters, since I met your mother ended.
他几集前刚上过我们的节目，自从《老爸老妈的浪漫史》结束以来，他有着最酷的履历，乔·凯利共同创作了《足球教练》和《底特律人》。
Just, I don't know, I just wanna shout out some of the Robbie Rashid, an amazing show called Atypical, just like very cool shit and Brenda writing for Pixar.
我就是想，不知道，我就是想感谢罗比·拉希德，一部叫《非典型少年》的惊艳剧集，真的很酷，还有布伦达为皮克斯写作。
So I just, I'm very proud of the Hemium alum writers and all they've gone on to do.
所以我只是，我为“海姆”校友编剧们以及他们后来取得的一切成就感到非常自豪。
Yeah, you know, there's a grand history in Hollywood of like certain writer's rooms having, you know, like Ben Stiller's show.
对啊，你知道的，好莱坞有一个伟大的传统，就是某些编剧室，比如本·斯蒂勒的节目。
Right?
对吧？
Early SNL or I think.
早期的《周六夜现场》，或者我觉得。
The Dana, kind of failed Dana Carby's sketch show at one of those writing steps.
达纳，有点像失败的达纳·卡维小品秀，就在那些编剧台阶上。
It's just like unbelievable.
这简直太不可思议了。
Yeah.
是啊。
So this episode is called The Waste of Treepla.
所以这一集叫做“The Waste of Treepla”。
You know what's funny?
你知道什么好笑吗？
We always talk about, and we always talk about how we met your mother is a mystery, but a lot of episodes begin with something mysterious happening, like brunch, you know, where like, Why is everyone being weird?
我们经常谈论，我们总是说《老爸老妈的浪漫史》是一个谜，但很多剧集都是从发生一些神秘的事情开始的，比如早午餐，你知道的，大家都表现得很奇怪？
Yeah.
对。
This title is a mystery.
这个标题就是一个谜。
Yeah.
对。
That is not solved until the very end.
直到最后才被解开。
The very, very end.
非常非常最后。
And I thought, I said to Joanna when we're watching, I said, did they say what it stood for?
我想，我在看的时候对乔安娜说，我说，他们说过这代表什么吗？
And she's like, I don't think so.
她说，我觉得没有。
But I was like, oh, that's the whole punch line of the episode.
但我想，哦，那是这一集的整个包袱。
That's the entire thing it's building towards.
那是整个故事铺垫的目标。
I love how you watch these episodes.
我喜欢你看这些剧集的方式。
And your next to your wife who's never seen the show.
你坐在从未看过这部剧的妻子旁边。
And you're both completely clueless about what's going to happen.
你们俩对接下来会发生什么完全一无所知。
And like, she's like, what's going to happen?
然后她说，会发生什么？
I'm like, don't look at me.
我说，别看我。
I don't write.
我又不是编剧。
It was a long time ago.
那是很久以前的事了。
That's why when fans come up to you with super specific questions and I'm like, I'm better able to answer them now.
这就是为什么当粉丝带着超级具体的问题来找你时，我会觉得我现在更能回答他们了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like for years, I was like, I don't even remember what you're talking about.
好几年里，我都觉得，我甚至不记得你在说什么。
Like this is like, I loved a few episodes ago.
就像几集之前，我很喜欢。
You're like, and I turned to Jordan, and I'm like, I think I know what the twist is gonna be.
你说，然后我转向乔丹，我说，我想我知道转折会是什么了。
I'm like, yeah, you fucking do.
我说，对啊，你丫的当然知道。
You know what the twist is gonna be.
你知道转折会是什么。
No man, I wasn't sure.
不，伙计，我不确定。
I was like, maybe I have a memory.
我当时想，也许我还有记忆。
Maybe that's it.
也许就是这样。
I thought I had solved it.
我以为我已经解开了。
I didn't even remember.
我甚至都不记得了。
I thought I was like intuiting it.
我还以为我是直觉想到的呢。
I'd most be boys that.
我可去你的吧。
You most be boys.
你可拉倒吧。
Oh, well, I love that so much.
哦，好吧，我太喜欢这样了。
And by the way, I am having every episode.
顺便说一句，我看每一集的时候。
There's multiple things where I go, oh, I completely forgot that.
都有好几次我会想，哦，我完全把这事忘光了。
Or I forgot that that happened in this episode.
或者我忘了这一集里发生过这个。
But yeah, I really like this episode a lot.
不过说真的，我真的很喜欢这一集。
So, do we sit your blood?
所以，我们是要测你的血吗？
Alec, tell us when this episode aired?
亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的？
This episode aired on November 5th, 2007.
这一集于2007年11月5日播出。
Okay.
好的。
And Craig, this is a little bit, I would say, sometimes we look at these episodes, we go, oh, this is actually a two-parter in certain ways, you know?
克雷格，这有点儿，我会说，有时我们看这些剧集时会想，哦，从某些方面来说这其实是个上下集，你知道吗？
This is part two of this kind of Lily Marshall economic anxiety, kind of a cliffhangerish at the end of the day.
这是莉莉和马歇尔经济焦虑的第二部分，归根结底有点像个悬念。
It was unresolved in the previous episode, which is on not that guy.
上一集里这个问题还没解决，也就是“不是那家伙”那一集。
And I really love how Marshall and Lily have this legitimate financial huge problem.
我真的很喜欢马歇尔和莉莉遇到了这种合法的巨大财务问题。
And Lillie has a secret, Marshall doesn't even know they're in these dire financial straits because Lillie's carrying around this huge secret.
莉莉有一个秘密，马歇尔甚至不知道他们陷入了如此可怕的财务困境，因为莉莉保守着这个巨大的秘密。
And I really like that you come into this episode with like this ticking time bomb of suspense.
我真的很喜欢这一集里那种悬念迭起、就像定时炸弹一样的感觉。
And so yeah, the three big threads in this episode are Marshall and Lillie being in this huge fiasco that Marshall doesn't know Lillie has run up this enormous debt due to this like shopping addiction.
所以，是的，这一集的三个主要线索是：马歇尔和莉莉陷入了这个巨大的烂摊子，而马歇尔不知道莉莉因为购物成瘾而欠下了巨额债务。
We see her at a meeting.
我们看到她去参加了一个聚会。
We literally see her at like a meeting for shopping addicts in this episode.
我们在这集里真地看到她去参加了类似购物狂互助会的聚会。
And they decide, they make the terrible, terrible decision to go in way over their heads and buy an apartment because they do, they make the textbook mistake of day one, they see one thing and they go, we have to have this.
他们决定——做出了一个极其糟糕的决定，那就是打肿脸充胖子去买一套公寓，因为他们犯了第一天的经典错误，看到一样东西就觉得：我们必须拥有它。
And by the way, I've absolutely done that.
顺便说一句，我绝对也干过这种事。
I am the guy that like will buy the first thing I see.
我就是那种会买下看到的第一样东西的人。
I have that part of Marshall is like me.
马歇尔身上有那一部分跟我很像。
So that's basically we're watching them over commit financially and Marshall doesn't even know that they're massively in debt.
所以基本上我们看到他们在财务上过度透支，而马歇尔甚至不知道他们已经负债累累。
And I love the way the suspense of that in this episode, it all comes out.
我很喜欢这一集里那种悬念，最后这一切都水落石出了。
Barney runs a very sociopathic side scheme where the apartment that his dear friends are trying to purchase.
巴尼策划了一个非常反社会的恶作剧：他好朋友们正试图买下的那套公寓……
He realizes he can pretend to be an interested buyer, steal the apartment key or the code password to get in as if he's a buyer who wants to see it when the realtor can't show it and just have sex with a woman in the apartment that his dear friends are going to try to buy and read the family.
他意识到自己可以假装成有意向的买家，在房产经纪人无法带看时，偷走公寓钥匙或密码进去假装看房，然后在他亲爱的好朋友们准备买下并建立家庭的那套公寓里和女人上床。
Not Barney's finest hour.
这可不是巴尼的高光时刻。
It's not as fun as Sarah, and he doesn't have a come up in this episode.
这不像萨拉那样有趣，而且他在这一集里也没有遭到报应。
I actually really miss, because we've been pretty good at tracking, like, well, when he goes too far, the sort of moral universe of the show is pretty good at giving him karma.
其实我真的觉得挺遗憾的，因为我们之前追踪得挺好的，比如，当他做得过分时，剧中的道德宇宙通常会很好地给他报应。
There is no repercussion in this one for as should he is.
而这一集里，无论他多么混蛋，都没有任何惩罚。
I could make an argument for the fact that when he, when he, this is way jumping head, so forgive me.
我可以为一件事辩护，那就是当他——当他——这有点跳跃到后面了，原谅我。
When he hears and fears that Marshall and Lily they're getting divorced and it devastates him.
当他听到并担心马歇尔和莉莉要离婚时，他崩溃了。
No, that, I think there's something about the fact that he's been such a slimy shithead in this episode.
不，我觉得关键在于他在这一集里表现得像个黏糊糊的混蛋。
That the thought that this one couple that actually is kind of carrying the torch for like his sentimental view of a good relationship, even though he makes fun of it all the time.
以至于一想到这对情侣——实际上某种程度上一直在延续他对美好关系的感性看法（尽管他总是拿这个开玩笑）……
And are like his parents, they're his model for like a good, happy couple.
而且就像他的父母一样，他们是他心目中美好、幸福情侣的模范。
They're parenting Barney in some ways.
他们在某些方面就像巴尼的父母一样管着他。
It's the Barney that says there's gonna be a baby.
这就是那个说“要有个孩子了”的巴尼。
Yeah, it's that Barney, yes.
对，就是那个巴尼，没错。
Really like you're right Barney's energy shifts in a really good way and also Barney is very much Cowed by Ted Barney is very into Ted This is Ted's little runner in this episode where Ted is a detective Ted is sighing the the and he's got his back fully Yes, yes exactly yeah, yeah, and like so and Barney really becomes Ted second in command He's really he really immediately looks up to dad So in the second half of this episode, after being a total shit, Barney does do a couple of things that are sort of like winning and sort of weirdly sweet.
真的，就像你说的，巴尼的状态发生了非常棒的转变，而且巴尼在很大程度上被泰德震慑住了。巴尼非常崇拜泰德。这是泰德在这集里的小桥段，泰德是个侦探，泰德在……而且他完全支持他。对，对，没错，对，对，所以巴尼真的成了泰德的副手。他真的立刻就仰慕起了泰德。所以在这一集的后半部分，在当够了混蛋之后，巴尼确实做了一些既有点像在赢得好感又有点诡异地贴心的事。
And he's definitely like willing to be Ted's like second in command in this crime scene they're investigating.
而且他绝对愿意在他们正在调查的这个犯罪现场当泰德的副手。
Yeah.
是的。
But those are the three threads.
但这就是那三条线索。
I do like, I like that even though they're kind of three little runners, you know, there's two runners off a main story.
我确实挺喜欢这种设置，尽管它们有点像三个小桥段，你知道的，主线之外有两个副线。
It's all off when this one big main story, the apartment that these people are purchasing who cannot afford it, and there's this huge secret.
这一切都源于这个宏大的主线：这对根本买不起房的人要买公寓，里面藏着一个巨大的秘密。
Everything kind of does come from that in this episode, which I like.
这一集里的所有事情基本上都由此展开，我挺喜欢这一点的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲子，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，言归正传。
There's something about Marshall and Lily, like they go first a lot.
马歇尔和莉莉有些地方很特别，比如他们总是冲在最前面。
Like they're the ones who go first.
就像他们总是先迈出第一步。
They're the first ones to be in a committed relationship.
他们是第一对确立长期恋爱关系的人。
First ones get married.
第一对结婚的人。
up into space ahead of everybody.
比所有人都提前一步冲向未来。
Yeah.
对。
Exactly.
确实。
And this thing of like, not just trying to rent an apartment, but buy an apartment, like they're in such like adult weeds here.
而且这种不只是想租公寓，而是要买公寓的事情，他们简直陷入了这种成年人的泥潭。
Yeah.
对。
That they're just overwhelmed.
以至于他们简直应接不暇。
And yeah.
没错。
And also, I mean, it's really funny what and we'll get here, but like tries to make this kind of like reactionary patriarchal argument, like I shouldn't even be a part of this.
而且，我的意思是，这真的很有趣，我们等会会聊到，莉莉试图提出这种反动式的父权论点，比如我甚至不该参与这事。
Can women even vote?
女人甚至能投票吗？
Why do?
为什么？
Yeah.
是啊。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
太逗了。
Yeah.
对。
So I love this look for Lily.
所以我很喜欢莉莉的这个造型。
I love that she is just in the wrong.
我喜欢她这次完全理亏。
She really fucked up.
她真的搞砸了。
And she has to come clean.
而且她必须坦白。
It's going to come out one way or the other.
总纸包不住火，事情迟早会败露。
And she really she lets it come out the worst way possible.
而她偏偏让事情以最糟糕的方式败露了。
They go in to actually like try to get the loan and it comes out like by a bank officer looking up her credit history.
他们去实际办理贷款时，竟然是被银行职员查了信用记录才败露的。
And that's when and she says, I wanted to be the first one to tell you this Marshall, which is hilarious.
然后就在这时，她说，我想成为第一个告诉你这件事的人，马修，这太荒谬了。
She so does not do the right thing in this delightful way.
她用这种绝妙的方式把事情彻底搞砸了。
By the way, the bank loan officer was hilarious.
顺便说一句，那个银行贷款职员太逗了。
He's great.
他演得真好。
He was so funny.
他太搞笑了。
Like the way he was laughing with Marshall and like his just like geniality and the whole thing was just really funny.
比如他跟马修开玩笑的方式，还有那种和气劲儿，整场戏真的非常搞笑。
Really, really funny, really natural and real.
真的，真的很搞笑，非常自然真实。
Like that is a good, you could study that little guest performance and be like, that's what you come in and do.
就像那是教科书般的表演，你可以研究那个小客串演出，然后会觉得，这才是你该有的表现。
You parachute into a show and you just go all in and you just play it and you just be part of, he was so effortlessly part of that scene, that actor.
你空降到一个节目里，全力以赴地去演，完全融入其中，那个演员毫无费力地就融入了那场戏。
We should look up his name and give him his proper tributes, Alec is on it, I can see him doing it as we speak.
我们应该查查他的名字，给他应有的赞誉，亚历克正在查，我能看到他边说边在查。
There's also something like, I wasn't there, when we filmed that obviously, I wasn't in the scene, I was probably at home, I wasn't on set even.
还有一种情况，我当时不在，我们拍那场戏时显然我不在，我不在那个场景里，我可能在家，甚至不在片场。
And if I didn't watch this episode, which there's no guarantee I did because I didn't watch a lot of the episodes, that was the first time I saw that performance, you know?
如果我没看这一集（这并不保证我看了，因为我很多集都没看），那是我第一次看到那段表演，你知道吗？
unless he was there at the run through, which I don't remember if he was.
除非他彩排时在场，我不记得他在不在了。
He might've been able to run through probably, unless of course he wasn't, and we hadn't cast out Rolli yet or something, but yeah, that's hilarious.
他可能参与了彩排吧，除非当然他不在，而且我们当时还没选定罗利的角色什么的，不过，对，这太搞笑了。
You know what else was good in this is Meg, poor Meg, that Barney is just fooling.
你知道这集里还有谁演得好吗？是梅格，可怜的梅格，巴尼一直在耍她。
She's really wants a commitment, and he's just such a shit to her.
她真的很想要一个承诺，而他对她却那么混账。
She was funny at that actress.
那个女演员很有趣。
She was good.
她演得很好。
Was that April?
那是阿普丽尔吗？
April, yeah.
阿普丽尔，对。
Were you friends with her?
你跟她是朋友吗？
I feel like you knew that.
我觉得你认识她。
I would see her over the years as she was always delightful.
这些年来我经常看到她，她总是那么讨人喜欢。
I think she was friends with Kobe.
我想她和科比是朋友。
Yeah, I feel like she was friends with somebody on the cast.
对，我觉得她和剧组里的某个人是朋友。
Yeah, she was great.
对，她太棒了。
No, she was really funny.
不，她真的很有趣。
And you know, those Barney girlfriend roles like could, I thought that the actresses who played them often made a lot of them, you know?
而且你知道，巴尼的那些女朋友角色，我常常觉得扮演她们的女演员们把这些角色发挥得很出色，你知道吗？
Like they could have been like kind of like dim, you know, kind of just girl of the week kind of energy.
她们本可能演成那种有点无脑的，你知道，有点像“每周女友”那种肤浅的感觉。
And she really brought something very sweet and open and It made it so much worse in the best in a good way.
而她真的带来了一种非常甜美、坦诚的特质，这反而让情况变得更糟糕，但以一种极好的方式。
Yes, but she was also like really alert to her own.
是的，而且她也对自己的状况非常清醒。
She was alert to her own damage, you know, like as a character.
作为角色，她对自己的创伤很清醒，你知道的。
Yeah, she very much was.
对，她确实非常清醒。
Okay.
好的。
It was Phil Lewis played the lone officer.
贷款职员是菲尔·刘易斯扮演的。
I guess April Bulby played April Bulby.
我想阿普丽尔·鲍尔比扮演的是阿普丽尔·鲍尔比。
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
对，对，对，对，对，对。
They were both great in this episode.
他们在这一集里都演得很棒。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, and there's this mystery.
对，这里还有一个谜团。
What does Debus of Chippewa mean?
奇帕瓦的德布斯是什么意思？
I really liked the running device of is what he should have said or is what she should have said or is what we should have said.
我很喜欢这种反复出现的桥段设计，比如“这才是他当时应该说的”或者“这才是她当时应该说的”或者“这才是我们当时应该说的”。
That was a very satisfying storytelling device that really was like this episode's thing and the little fantasy pops about how they I like seeing also the Marshall Lilly weren't completely on the same page about their future the four kids the two kids lilies has a secret.
这是一个非常令人满意的叙事手法，确实成了这一集的特色，还有那些关于他们幻想的小插曲我也很喜欢，看到马修和莉莉对他们的未来并不是完全意见一致——四个孩子？两个孩子？莉莉有个秘密。
I like how this presents like they are just happy excited young married couple but she does not absolutely paradise perfect you know she has a huge secret and they're making a terrible decision that's really going to complicate their lives and I like it because it gives you you can we're setting up stuff for the whole season with this apart.
我喜欢这种呈现方式：他们看起来像是幸福、兴奋的年轻已婚夫妇，但绝对不是世外桃源般的完美，你知道的，她有一个巨大的秘密，而且他们正在做一个会彻底打乱他们生活的糟糕决定，我喜欢这样，因为这为整季关于这套公寓的故事埋下了伏笔。
and a huge decision and this huge problem they have.
这是一个重大的决定，也是他们面临的巨大问题。
Well, it's also real estate.
嗯，这也是房地产的问题。
We want it to be incredibly logical.
我们希望它是极其理性的。
It is a highly emotional thing.
但这其实是一件极具情绪化的事情。
Totally.
完全是这样。
Buying property, you know, like buying property and saying like, this is where we're gonna live.
买房，你知道的，买房然后说：“这就是我们要住的地方。”
This is where we're gonna raise our children.
“这就是我们要抚养孩子的地方。”
This is one of the most emotional things you can do.
这是你能经历的最具情绪化的事情之一。
Like moving, buying apartments and moving.
就像搬家、买公寓再搬家。
It's so displacement.
这会带来极大的流离失所感。
It's one of the top three stressors.
这是排名前三的压力源之一。
It's one of the way up there.
它的压力指数非常高。
Yeah.
对。
I like that, I like that what you said about Marshall and Lilly being the first.
我喜欢这个，我喜欢你关于马修和莉莉是先驱的说法。
like they're the like chimp sent up into space to see if it's possible for like humans to then go.
就像他们是被送上太空的黑猩猩，来测试人类随后前往是否可行。
They serve that role in this group in this interesting way.
他们以这种有趣的方式在这个群体中扮演了这样的角色。
And they're having to make, they're not only going first, they're making the mistake first.
而且他们不仅是第一个尝试的，还是第一个犯错的。
They're making huge mistakes.
他们犯了滔天大错。
They're stepping in it, you know?
他们踩进大坑里了，你知道吗？
I really liked jumping all over here, but I really liked Marshall's, Marshall finds out his wife lied to him and ran up a huge debt.
我很喜欢——话题有点跳跃——但我真的很喜欢马修的反应，马修发现他的妻子对他撒了谎，还欠下了巨额债务。
And I like the mystery of what happened, Why did they place the call to a divorce lawyer?
我喜欢事件背后的谜团：他们为什么要给离婚律师打电话？
And it's very funny that she's, that was her solution.
而且她的解决办法非常搞笑。
She's like, if we get divorced, you can just buy the apartment in your name.
她说：“如果我们离婚了，你就可以以你个人的名义买下这套公寓了。”
But I like, which was a funny weird twist.
但我喜欢这个奇怪又搞笑的转折。
And it was there to be like a mislead about them getting divorced, Barney falling apart was hilarious.
这就像是一个关于他们要离婚的误导，巴尼崩溃的样子太搞笑了。
I liked the sentiment, Marshall said, of when I married you, I also married all your problems.
我很喜欢马修说的那种情感：“当我娶了你，我也娶了你所有的麻烦。”
I married all the good parts, but I also married all your problems.
“我接受了你所有的优点，但我也接受了你所有的麻烦。”
I'm not going to run from those problems.
“我不会逃避这些麻烦。”
I know I didn't know about this one, but I did sign up for this.
“我知道我之前不知道这件事，但我确实接受了这一切。”
just like you signed up for whatever my shit is.
“就像你也接受了我身上的种种烂摊子一样。”
He's not good at buying an apartment, but he's very good at being a husband when the chips are down.
他不擅长买公寓，但在遭遇困境时，他非常擅长做一个好丈夫。
Yeah.
对。
I love what he said there.
我很喜欢他在那里的发言。
And Siegel played that great, and that does make you love them.
席格把那场戏演得太棒了，那真的会让人爱上他们。
But Lily really messed up.
但莉莉真的搞砸了。
Lily really, when he was saying that Jordana was watching it very stressed out, being like, this is really bad.
当他说那番话时，乔丹娜在一旁看得很紧张，心想：这可真糟啊。
So stressed and only got more stressed in this episode.
超级紧张，而且在这一集里变得越来越紧张。
Part of the emotionality of buying a place, especially if you're newly married and want to start a family, the flash forwards of them with their kids and the difference between what they're seeing and what they're feeling, like Marshall, you know, leading the Erickson family players in the band.
买房子的这种情感体验，特别是如果你新婚燕尔还想组建家庭的话，闪现出他们和孩子的画面，以及他们看到的和感受到的之间的差异，比如马歇尔，你知道的，带领埃里克森家族成员在乐队里演出。
Yes.
是的。
And then Lily's kids are, of course, great visual artists and they're going to be showing at the Met and all this.
然后莉莉的孩子们当然都是伟大的视觉艺术家，他们将在大都会博物馆办展，诸如此类。
And what was it, Chocolate Pancakes, versus crypto, yeah, I really like that stuff.
还有那个什么，巧克力煎饼对决加密货币，对，我真的很喜欢那些桥段。
And it is, it's so human, right?
而且确实如此，这太人性化了，对吧？
You just start picturing a life.
你开始畅想一种生活。
There's, they did everything you're not supposed to do.
他们，他们做了所有不该做的事。
You, you start getting way too excited about the very first place you see.
你，你会对看到的第一个地方感到过于兴奋。
You don't do much research and it felt very human to me.
你没有做太多调查，我觉得这非常真实接地气。
I feel like I've done this.
我觉得我也干过这事。
Yeah.
对。
I know people who like you buy a place, but you only saw it during the day.
我认识这样的人，就像你买了个地方，但你只在白天看过它。
And you didn't realize there was like a club.
然后你没意识到那底下居然有个俱乐部。
Yeah, underneath it or something.
对，或者类似的东西。
at night.
在晚上。
Or it's by the train, like you don't reel.
或者它挨着火车站，你根本没意识到。
There's so many things especially in New York.
有太多事情了，特别是在纽约。
You've got to go there and you have to find a way to go there at night.
你得去实地看看，而且你得想办法在晚上去一趟。
They do none of the right things.
他们什么正确的做法都没做。
And they realize they were also scammed by the realtor who was only showing the apartment on the weekend when the sewage treatment plant wasn't operational, which they were seduced in by her.
然后他们发现自己还被房地产经纪人给坑了，那个经纪人只在周末污水处理厂不运作的时候带看公寓，他们就这样被她给忽悠了。
We bought a place in Brooklyn right across from this elementary school, which is fantastic because you know, you hear kids playing during the day, which is fine, really sweet, but also it's not too tall, so we get good light in through all of those.
我们在布鲁克林买了个地方，就在一所小学对面，这太棒了，因为你知道的，白天你能听到孩子们玩耍的声音，这挺好的，真的很温馨，而且楼层不是很高，所以所有这些房间都能照进很好的光线。
And also like, it's like a school, right?
而且还有，这就像是一所学校，对吧？
Like it's a quiet block.
就像这是一个安静的街区。
It's gonna be quiet at night.
晚上肯定会很安静。
Yeah.
对。
But now they started doing renovations on this school.
但现在他们开始对这所学校进行翻修了。
I mean, the whole thing is covered in scaffolding and they only work on the weekends in the evening now.
我的意思是，整栋建筑都盖满了脚手架，而且他们现在只在周末和晚上施工。
I like, I can hear them working on this school right now.
我简直，我现在就能听到他们在学校里施工的声音。
There's no way you could have predicted that though.
不过这事你无论如何也预料不到。
No, no.
对，对。
You just got fucked.
你就是被坑惨了。
We lived here for two years before they started doing this renovation of this school.
在这所学校开始翻修之前，我们已经在里头住了两年了。
That's really funny.
这真的太搞笑了。
It's massive.
规模太大了。
Yeah.
对。
Maggie Wheeler, Alec.
玛吉·惠勒，亚历克。
Is that Maggie Wheeler?
那是玛吉·惠勒吗？
Yeah.
对。
Who was on Friends was hilarious is Janice on Friends.
演过《老友记》的那个，太搞笑了吧，就是《老友记》里的珍妮丝。
Yeah.
对。
She's very.
她非常有……
And went to Wesley and I think, right, Alec?
而且去过韦尔斯利学院，对吧，亚历克？
Yeah.
对。
That's what you were saying.
你刚才就是这么说的。
I read your mind.
我猜到你的心思了。
See, we still got it, buddy.
你看，我们宝刀未老，老兄。
Maggie Wheeler, a couple of years ago, I went to see Bonnie Light Horseman.
玛吉·惠勒，几年前我去看了“邦妮·莱特·霍斯曼”乐队的演出。
Do you know that band?
你知道那个乐队吗？
They're a great band.
他们是个很棒的乐队。
No.
不知道。
Yeah.
对。
Great band.
很棒的乐队。
And I saw her.
然后我看到她了。
She tapped me on the shoulder and she reintroduced herself.
她拍了拍我的肩膀，重新做了自我介绍。
Oh, that's really funny.
哦，那真的太搞笑了。
She's really sweet.
她人真的很好。
Yeah, she's great.
对，她超棒。
When she was a good realtor, because you did sense that there were ice in those veins, and she did totally mislead Marshall and Lily.
她演了个优秀的房产经纪人，因为你能感觉到她笑里藏刀，而且她确实把马歇尔和莉莉彻底给忽悠了。
I will say, long after this episode, and yeah, this is a little bit jumping ahead, later you realize that not only does it smell like sewage treatment, this neighborhood dough with the triplet downwind of the sewage treatment plant, you also learn in a later episode that the whole apartment is like on a slant and the chit just rolls across the apartment.
我得说，在这集播出很久之后——是的，这有点剧透了——后来你发现，不仅这附近闻起来有污水处理厂的味道，这个位于污水处理厂下风向的街区（取名为“臭气熏天的特里普拉”），你在后来的剧集里还会得知，整间公寓居然是倾斜的，东西会直接一路滚过整个房间。
I, we, after how much mother ended, we bought a place in Tribeca.
我，我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》结束之后，在翠贝卡买了个地方。
I still live in this place in Tribeca, another New York neighborhood triangle below Canal, Tribeca, Daoistatripla.
我现在还住在翠贝卡这个地方，这是纽约的另一个街区，运河街以南的三角形区域，翠贝卡（Tribeca，即 Triangle Below Canal）。
That's what we're playing off of in addition to, no man in Dumbo and all the things, but I bought this apartment and realized many months in living here that the floor was incredibly slanted because I bought like, I bought a desk chair for my wife who did a desk chair and I think this is not a very romantic gift, but I for some shitty gift and for some holiday, I bought her a desk chair with like rolling wheels on it showing them around.
除了Dumbo（下曼哈顿区）和各种地方之外，我们当时就是按这个梗来玩的，但我买了这间公寓后，住了好几个月才发现地板简直倾斜得离谱，因为我买了一个——我给我老婆买了一张办公椅，她想要个办公椅，我觉得这可能不是什么浪漫的礼物，但我为了某个烂节日送了她一份烂礼物，我给她买了一张带滚轮的办公椅，放在屋里滑来滑去。
And we needed to trade it out because the chair would just roll across the floor like a ghost chair on its own.
然后我们得把它换掉，因为那椅子自己就会像个幽灵椅子一样在地板上滑来滑去。
And I was like, we're leaving Marshall in the least thing years after we'd wrote it.
当时我想，我们在剧集完结多年后，竟然落得跟马歇尔一样的下场。
It's like, this is after how much mother ended and I'm still, I still live in that apartment.
就像是，这是《老爸老妈浪漫史》完结之后的事了，而我还在，我至今还住在那个公寓里。
It's a good apartment, but shit will roll across the floor in certain rooms.
那是个好公寓，但有些房间里的东西就是会一路滚过地板。
It's like a hundred, something years old.
那房子有一百多年历史了。
It's an old school Tribeca, like, you know, lofty kind of building and used to be storage.
那是老派的翠贝卡风格，你知道的，有点像阁楼那种建筑，以前是用来当仓库的。
I feel like this connection to the Stowess Retripla episode, because I do love living in Tribeca.
我觉得这跟那个“臭气熏天的特里普拉”一集很有渊源，因为我真的很喜欢住在翠贝卡。
I do love my apartment.
我真的很喜欢我的公寓。
We've lived here the entire time since him, you met it.
自从认识你之后，我们一直都住在这里。
But we're always discovering new fucked up things in our apartment.
但我们总能在公寓里发现各种新的操蛋问题。
And we didn't robustly, we were shopping for it from LA during the final season of amateur mother and just not able to really do the research, not able to come at night, not able to do all the things.
而且我们当时买房时可没怎么实地考察，我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》最后一季拍摄期间从洛杉矶买的房，根本没法好好做调查，没法在晚上去看房，没法做所有那些该做的事。
And you're just, it's such a leap of faith.
这完全就是一场孤注一掷的豪赌。
It is such a big deal.
这真的是一件大事。
You're pouring a lot of money into this thing.
你把大笔的钱都砸在这玩意儿上面了。
Marshally, do not have this amount of money.
马歇尔他们根本没有这么多钱。
And it's such a vulnerable act.
而且这是一种极其脆弱的行为。
And to go and complete that act and sign on the dotted line and then realize how badly you fucked it up is, it's very visceral at the end of that episode.
等你完成了这一套流程并在虚线上签了字，然后才意识到自己把它搞砸得有多彻底时，那种感觉在那一集的结尾是非常真切痛心的。
I think everyone can relate to that moment.
我想每个人都能对那个时刻感同身受。
Like, did I just blow it in this huge way?
就像是：我是不是把这件大事给彻底搞砸了？
We're gonna be locked here for years.
我们要被死死栓在这个地方好多年了。
Anyway, it's very, it's stressful, but I think we captured the reality of buying a place.
总之，这压力太大了，但我觉得我们捕捉到了买房子的现实真相。
Did you know, do you know the neighborhood Guwanis in Brooklyn?
你知道吗，你知道布鲁克林的戈瓦纳斯（Gowanus）这个街区吗？
Yeah.
知道。
So I just looked this up to make sure that I have it.
所以我刚刚查了一下，确保我没记错。
And this is just, this is just a Google search.
这只是，这只是个谷歌搜索。
The Guwanis Canal in Brooklyn is a highly contaminated EPA superfund site.
布鲁克林的戈瓦纳斯运河是一个严重污染的美国环保署超级基金遗址。
Decades of industrial activity have left behind how is this pollutants, including coal tar and PCBs that are known to cause cancer, residents have raised significant concerns about cancerous and high levels of toxic carcinogenic vapors leaking into nearby buildings.
几十年的工业活动留下了可怕的污染物，包括已知会导致癌症的煤焦油和多氯联苯（PCBs），居民们对癌症高发以及大量有毒致癌蒸气泄漏到附近建筑中表示了严重担忧。
And I think for a time, Gowanus became like a very hit place to live because they were discounting it quite a bit.
而且我觉得有一段时间，戈瓦纳斯变得非常热门，因为那里的房价打了很大折扣。
Yes, stuff came out.
对，消息传出去了。
Yeah, totally.
对，完全是这样。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对的。
It really ain't exploded.
它确实爆发了。
I feel like it exploded because people can actually afford to be there.
我觉得它之所以爆发，是因为人们终于买得起那里的房子了。
It's great, it's great.
这很棒，真的很棒。
There's great whole foods that I go to there.
那里有一家很棒的全食超市（Whole Foods），我会去。
I've been to that Whole Foods many times when visiting Brooklyn and visiting my relatives there.
我每次去布鲁克林看望亲戚时，都去过那家全食超市好多次了。
And they've cleaned up that canal in a huge way.
而且他们已经对那条运河进行了大规模的清理。
I think it's way better and I'm sure now no one can afford an apartment there anymore.
我觉得现在好多了，而且我敢肯定现在已经没人买得起那里的公寓了。
No, it's super nice now.
不，现在这里好极了。
But at the time it was like, artists were pouring in because they're like, hey, there's good rent here.
但在当时，艺术家们纷纷涌入，因为他们觉得，嘿，这里的房租很便宜。
But I also think that New York, there's different ways to tell stories in New York.
但我也觉得纽约，在纽约有各种不同的讲故事方式。
Like you can do a kind of rom-com Upper West Side, no gum on the sidewalk, kind of like sheen to things.
比如你可以拍那种上西区的浪漫喜剧，人行道上没有口香糖，一切都带点光鲜亮丽的感觉。
Or you can do like a little more of like a low-ree side, like what I was trying to do in my first film, Happy Thank You More, please, was like, I literally said in my Sim Talk, for like, I want to feel the gum on the sidewalks.
或者你可以拍一点下东区风格的作品，就像我在我的第一部电影《再见吾爱》里尝试做的那样，我当时在简报里直说，我就想感受一下人行道上的口香糖。
Like, I want to feel the kind of like below 14th Street prime of the whole thing.
就像，我想感受那种14街以下、整个地方最原始的活力。
And I think that, how I made my mother, even though it was like kind of glossy and well lit, you guys from the writer's perspective, were really interested in like the cock-a-mouse and Joey Satripla and the things about New York crying on the subway, the things about New York that really are very specific, that, you know, one thing, you know, my wife is a native New Yorker, she grew up on the Upper East Side, and she's really delighting, this is her first time watching it, as our listeners know, but she's really delighting in the super specific New Yorkiness of it all, but the thing that I think you guys do is it both winks to native New Yorkers or people who live here.
而且我觉得，我如何创作《老妈》，尽管它看起来有点光鲜亮丽且灯光很好，但从你们编剧的角度来看，你们真的很关注像杂货铺、约瑟夫·萨特里普拉，以及诸如在地铁里哭泣这些极具纽约特质的事情，这些非常具体的事情——你知道的，我的妻子是个地道的纽约人，她在上东区长大，正如我们的听众所知，这是她第一次看这部剧，她真的感到非常高兴，因为这剧里有超级具象的纽约风情，但我觉得你们最厉害的地方在于，它既向土生土长的纽约人或住在这里的人递了个眼色。
And says, you know what we're talking about, right?
然后说，你知道我们在说什么对吧？
But if you don't live here, let's say you live in Austria, where the lovely letter came from, it makes you feel like you know New York, or that it gives you like trade secrets, like a little bit of insider knowledge about New York.
但如果你不住在这里，比方说你住在奥地利——那封可爱的信就是从那里寄来的——它会让你觉得你很了解纽约，或者它会给你一种商业机密般的感觉，就像关于纽约的内部小秘密一样。
And I also like, it makes it this organic living character out of New York.
而且我也觉得，它把纽约变成了一个有机的、活生生的角色。
It feels very like Harry Potter worlds, like Diagon Alley, like Doha Satripla, Like, there's always gonna be some new part of this that you haven't found yet.
感觉非常像《哈利·波特》的世界，比如对角巷，比如多哈·萨特里普拉，就像，这里总会有一些你还没发现的新部分。
It's a little bit magical.
这多多少少有点魔幻。
Maybe it's bad magic sometimes, but there's magic in it somehow.
也许有时是坏魔法，但里面总有某种魔法。
And also the local characters that populate.
还有那些充斥其中的当地特色人物。
The thing about New York, and we've talked about this, but like, we live in this area of Brooklyn that's just like a couple square blocks with a park, right?
关于纽约，我们之前也讨论过，我们住在布鲁克林的这个区域，只有几个街区和一个公园，对吧？
Like, it's beautiful, but it's like, it is a neighborhood.
它很美，但它确实是一个社区。
Like, I see that we go on a walk every morning.
我看到我们每天早晨都会去散步。
We see the same people, you know?
我们会遇到同样的人，你知道吗？
Yeah, totally.
对，完全是这样。
I do think that there are these, you know, even like seeing Moripovitch, like there's just these little wings of New York City-ness that you guys did and threaded throughout.
我的确觉得，有这些，你知道的，甚至就像看到莫里波维奇那样，你们创作并贯穿其中的全都是这些纽约特色的小细节。
I think it's very satisfying, whether you live here or don't.
我觉得不管你住不住在这里，都会觉得非常满足。
Yeah, I know, totally.
对，我懂，完全如此。
I really like, I really like the idea that there's always gonna be some neighborhood you never heard of and some newly created idea.
我真的很喜欢这种想法，总会有一个你从未听说过的社区，以及某种新创造的构想。
You don't know exactly where this is, like you see the bridge, a bridge out the window of Doha, Citriplum, like maybe it's like, that's the bridge, like that's on the east side and they're like, Roosevelt Island is out the window or something.
你并不确切知道这里是哪里，就像你透过多哈·萨特里普拉的窗户看到了一座桥，桥就在窗外，也许那就是——那是东区的一座桥，他们会说，罗斯福岛就在窗外什么的。
But we do it.
但我们就是这样做的。
It's very unclear exactly where no issue people is.
“无事生非”究竟在哪里，其实非常模糊。
Not long ago, my wife and I, for many years, we had to commute back and forth from Tribeca to the Upper West Side because there's so much school in the Upper West Side.
不久前，我和妻子多年来不得不往返于翠贝卡和上西区之间，因为上西区有太多的学校。
And there's this little pocket on the West Side highway.
西区高速公路上有一个这样的小角落。
Some New Yorkers will know what I'm talking about that was right past a sewage treatment plant.
有些纽约人会明白我在说什么，它刚好就在一个污水处理厂旁边。
And it smells like shit.
那味道真他妈臭。
Every so often, you just catch the right day and the right moment.
每隔一段时间，只要赶上对的日子和对的时机，你就会闻到。
It smells fucking terrible.
味道糟糕透顶。
And we would sometimes walk that whole length.
我们有时会走完全程。
You can go drop off or we drop off our son and the upper side and then walk it back to try back a like huge long lock.
你可以去送孩子，或者我们在上西区放下儿子，然后一路走回翠贝卡，这是一段超级漫长的步行。
It's like takes two hours and we walk past that.
大概要花两个小时，我们会从那里走过。
And my wife at one point was like, oh my God, is this dough is a tree play?
我妻子有一次就说：“天哪，这就是多哈·萨特里普拉吗？”
Is this what you were writing about?
“这就是你写的东西吗？”
I was like, no, we don't know where dough is a tree play is.
我说：“不，我们根本不知道多哈·萨特里普拉在哪里。”
But in this great way, it's just like this magical, it really feels like Harry Potter world.
但从这种绝妙的方式来看，它就像是这种魔幻的存在，真的感觉像是《哈利·波特》的世界。
Like it's just this pocket of London.
就像伦敦的这么一个角落。
And you go back to the next day and it's not there.
你第二天再去，它就不在了。
It's not there anymore.
它不在了。
It moves around the city.
它在城市里移来移去。
And I feel like I love that vibe on this show.
我觉得我很喜欢这部剧里的这种氛围。
We created this universe.
我们创造了这个宇宙。
It's a little bit magic and weird.
它带点魔幻色彩，也有点古怪。
I don't know where it goes.
我不知道三倍体（Triple）在什么地方，但它确实在某个地方。
The triple is, but it's somewhere.
(注：上一句中Triple系语音识别错误，应为Doppio-Satriplis，即前文的多哈·萨特里普拉，此处按原意和上下文逻辑翻译)。
And I was like, essentially this, I said to her, this isn't what we thought of.
基本上就是这样，我对她说，这不是我们想的那样。
I don't think this place smelled this way.
我觉得这个地方以前不应该是这个味道的。
And our 20s, when we lived here, this is a newer sewage treatment plant that has been set up, I believe.
在我们20多岁住在这里的时候，据我所知，这是一个后来新建的污水处理厂。
But I was like, this might as well be it.
但我想，这就当作是吧。
This is the observation that was at work and it really does exist.
这就是当时观察到的现象，而且它确实存在。
You know, I'll have to fact check this with Jordana to make sure, but I'm 99% certain that her older half brother, his mother remarried a guy who was the guy who named Dumbo.
你知道的，我得向乔丹娜核实一下以确保准确，但我有99%的把握，她同母异父的大哥的母亲，后来嫁给的那个人就是给“丹波”（Dumbo）命名的人。
That's crazy.
这太疯狂了。
That's so crazy because I was also just thinking like it was not called Dumbo when I lived here in my 20s.
简直太疯狂了，因为我刚才也在想，我20多岁住在曼哈顿的时候，这里根本不叫Dumbo。
No one referred to it that way.
没有人会那样称呼它。
And that's what we're saying that there's always going to be some new down under the Manhattan Bridge overpass, right?
这就是我们所说的，曼哈顿大桥过街天桥下方（Down Under the Manhattan Bridge Overpass）总会有新的代称出现，对吧？
Yep.
没错。
That's it.
就是这样。
Yeah, there's always going to be that.
对，总会有这种变化的。
There will always be, it's a city of constant reinvention.
永远都会有，这是一座不断重塑的城市。
And it like, I'm not, maybe it's not called there was a cheap look in future Ted's world in 2030.
而且我觉得，也许在2030年未来老泰德的世界里，它不叫这个。
Maybe it's not called that anymore.
也许它不再叫那个名字了。
But at that moment, it was just the new term.
但在那个时候，它只是个新词。
No one knew what it meant.
没人知道它是什么意思。
But they were too afraid and embarrassed to admit.
但他们又太害怕、太尴尬而不敢承认。
When I first heard Dumbo, I was living in LA.
我第一次听到Dumbo这个词时，我住在洛杉矶。
People started calling it Dumbo while in LA.
人在洛杉矶时，大家就开始叫它Dumbo了。
And I was like, what is that?
当时我就想，那是什么？
I think it was called Dumbo long before you realized.
我觉得早在你意识到之前，这里就叫Dumbo了。
It's called Dumbo, yeah.
它就叫Dumbo，对。
it.
它。
I never heard it in my whole life and living in my 20s New York.
我在纽约度过20多岁的时候，一辈子都没听过这个词。
I feel like I never heard that term.
我觉得我从来没听过这个说法。
There's just so great.
真是太棒了。
It's so New York that no lead up like just the thing.
这太有纽约特色了，没有铺垫，直奔主题。
Yeah.
对。
So no lead done by it's all these things.
所以没有铺垫，直接就是Dumbo，就是这些东西。
Yeah.
对。
So we knew we wanted to do a play on that.
所以我们知道我们想在这方面做点文章。
And I think this is very much a Carter Bayes invention downwind.
我觉得这很大程度上是卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays）的创意——下风处（Downwind）。
Downwind is a sewage treatment plan.
下风处是一个污水处理厂。
This is some Carter Bayes brilliance because Carter He loves New York City, he's from Cleveland, he's an outsider, but he fell in love with New York.
这就是卡特·贝斯的高明之处，因为卡特他热爱纽约市，他来自克利夫兰，是个外地人，但他爱上了纽约。
He always loved this exact thing we're talking about of like the mythology of New York.
他一直很喜欢我们正在谈论的这种东西，也就是纽约的神话色彩。
We literally wrote a pilot years later after how much of a mother called New York Mythological that plays with that idea of an actually magic New York City that failed the pilots out there.
我们在几年后写过一部试播集，名字叫《纽约神话》（New York Mythological），玩的就是那种“实际上存在一个充满魔力的纽约市”的概念，那部试播集后来没被看中。
It was fun.
那挺有意思的。
It's like a Buffy kind of New York thing.
有点像《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》（Buffy）那种纽约风格的东西。
And it was again just diving even deeper into that feeling of like New York is a ever-shifting magical place that can't quite be explained logically.
这再次深入探讨了那种感觉：纽约是一个不断变化的、充满魔力的地方，无法用逻辑完全解释。
That pilot was taken by a great podcast called Dead Pilots Society, and a table read was organized for it.
那部试播集被一个很棒的播客节目《已死试播集协会》（Dead Pilots Society）看中了，并为它组织了一场围读。
This is like a month or two, a couple months ago, and it exists on Dead Pilots Society, and we're gonna drop it into our feet.
这大概是一两个月前的事，它现在就在《已死试播集协会》里，我们打算把它放到我们自己的节目源里。
It's called New York Mythological.
它叫做《纽约神话》。
It plays even more with this concept of like the magic of New York.
它更多地探讨了这种纽约魔力的概念。
Like the, and all of them.
比如，诸如此类。
Who was in it?
里面都有谁？
Are there any of the actors that you've worked with before that were in it?
里面有任何你以前合作过的演员吗？
CalPenn is in the table read for New York.
卡尔·潘（Cal Penn）参加了《纽约神话》的围读。
CalPenn, my neighbor.
卡尔·潘，我的邻居。
Your neighbor.
你的邻居。
I know that because he's also across from the school.
我知道这一点，因为他也住在学校对面。
We took him out to dinner to thank him for doing that a few weeks ago because he did that table read for us like a zoom table read.
几周前我们带他出去吃晚饭，感谢他做的那件事，因为他为我们做了一次剧本围读，就像Zoom剧本围读那样。
And he revealed that he was your neighbor and he sees you quite frequently proving your point about your neighborhoodiness.
然后他透露说他是你的邻居，而且他经常看到你，这证明了你关于“邻里风情”的观点。
Yes.
是的。
And one of the people in the solids in our band Becky Lichtenfeld is right around the corner from you and the same neighborhood.
而且我们乐队Solids的成员之一贝基·利希滕费尔德（Becky Lichtenfeld）就住在你拐角不远处的同一个社区。
It really is like you live in a little like Sesame Street road.
这真的就像你住在一条芝麻街似的小路上。
She's one of the she's one of the local like regulars we see on our walk.
她是我们散步时经常看到的当地老面孔之一。
she says she sees you.
她说她经常看到你。
You both have your dogs all the time.
你们俩总是带着狗。
All the time.
总是这样。
And by the way, the dead pilot sighted, that's all, if you're listening to this podcast and you are, it's in here.
顺便说一句，被否决的试播集，就这样，如果你在听这个播客（而你也确实在听），它就在这里。
It's already up.
已经上线了。
It's already on the feet.
已经在节目列表里了。
Okay.
好的。
Strolled up.
走起。
So you will, you will, is a funny half hour romantic comedy in a magical tinge, New York.
所以你会看到，这是一个发生在充满魔幻色彩的纽约的有趣的半小时浪漫喜剧。
And it's really funny, Cal, Cal Penn plays this guy that has had a curse put on him.
而且真的很有趣，卡尔·潘（Cal Penn）饰演一个被诅咒的家伙。
He did wrong one woman who turned out to be a witch.
他做错了事，惹了一个后来发现是女巫的女人。
is that a curse put on him that every woman in New York thinks they had a one-night stand with him and he never called them.
也就是被下了一个诅咒：纽约的每个女人都觉得她们和他有过一夜情，而他却从来不打电话给她们。
So his life has been going on for years.
所以他的生活就这样持续了好几年。
His life has been spent in New York, walking to the street, having women go, fuck you!
他的大半人生都是在纽约度过的，走在街上，女人们会对他喊：“去你的！”
Carl Hobbes, you motherfucker!
“卡尔·霍布斯，你这个混蛋！”
Like that's been his whole life.
他的整个人生差不多就是这样。
And the whole episode is, can we figure out how to free this poor man of this?
整集的内容就是：我们能不能想办法把这个可怜的男人从这种境地中解救出来？
He did do one wrong thing.
他的确做了一件错事。
He did hook up and have one, but he was the wrong woman.
他的确和别人发生了一夜情，但那是个错误的女人。
He scorns the wrong woman who turns out to be a witch who lives on the Upper East Side.
他惹恼了一个错误的女人，而那个女人竟然是个住在上东区的女巫。
It was basically took the dating and magic of New York and just took it a little bit further than him and was able to.
这基本上是把纽约的约会文化和魔术色彩稍微推进一步，并成功实现了。
I wish that one had gone, but it's sold to CBS.
我真希望那个剧能拍成，但它被卖给了哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）。
We developed it for like half year.
我们开发了大约半年。
We're going at CBS.
我们当时在CBS进展顺利。
We just finished how I met your mother.
我们刚拍完《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
This is going to be on, man.
心想：这回要火了，伙计。
This will be our show we shoot and do in New York.
这将是我们要在纽约拍摄和制作的节目。
That did not happen, but it is now available for you as a table re-ident on my Friday.
虽然没能拍成，但它现在已经作为剧本围读版在我的节目里供你收听了。
And this old man, he must admit he fell in love with you, new York City.
这个老人必须承认，他确实爱上了纽约市。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼（Alex Goldman），《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：为什么我挂倒挡时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果你有一个问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
在各大播客平台或访问hyperfixedpod.com即可收听。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I really thought it was funny.
我真的觉得它很有趣。
For some reason, the shot of Ted and Barney just getting loaded on the couch.
不知为什么，泰德和巴尼在沙发上喝得烂醉的那个镜头。
I love, again, it's like Ted is like this single guy of the season.
我喜欢——再说一次，泰德就像是这一季的单身汉。
Ted is in this new, I think Hemington called it a few episodes ago, free-ranged Ted.
泰德正处于一种新的状态，我想赫明顿（Hemington）几集前称之为“放养的泰德”。
Ted is leaning into being single again, and it includes being a shitty roommate to the married couple that has jobs.
泰德开始欣然接受再次单身的生活，其中就包括对那对有工作的已婚夫妇当一个糟糕的室友。
And I really liked him and Barney just being trouble for this married couple.
我真的很喜欢他和巴尼给这对已婚夫妇找麻烦的情节。
Well, I like the shot of it before the reveal.
嗯，我很喜欢揭晓前的那个镜头。
It was very pleasing to me for some reason, because it was like, it's not Ted and Barney in the bar, it's not them on the prowl, there's no women around.
不知为什么，它让我感觉非常舒服，因为就像，泰德和巴尼不在酒吧里，他们没有在四处搭讪，周围也没有女人。
Just hanging out on the couch.
只是在沙发上闲逛。
That feels very real to me in your 20s.
这让我想起二十几岁时非常真实的感觉。
Like, what are we gonna do in right?
比如，我们接下来要做什么？
I don't know, let's each have eight to 10.
我不知道，不如每人喝个八到十杯吧。
Like what?
比如什么？
On your couch?
在你的沙发上？
On the couch.
在沙发上。
And go nowhere.
而且哪儿也不去。
哪儿也不去。
You know what it was?
你知道那是什么吗？
And just talk shit, you know.
就是胡侃聊天，你知道的。
What it was a reference to where you cut wide and you see them at Marshall and Lilliard and Trich.
那是一个镜头切到全景，然后你看到他们和马歇尔、莉莉以及特里奇在一起的梗。
Please stop.
请住手。
It's the bunk bed joke.
这就是双层床的笑话。
It's dead in the bunk bed.
双层床的梗已经过时了。
But you've done that a couple of times in the first couple of seasons.
不过在前几季里，你们已经用过好几次这种手法了。
You should come, there should be a name for that kind of reveal.
你们应该来，这种揭晓方式应该起个名字。
It's like a pop wide kind of reveal that.
就像是一种突然切到全景的揭晓方式。
Very jarring, wide cut, totally different angle.
非常突兀的全景切换，完全不同的角度。
We're just in a different movie.
我们简直就像在拍另一部电影。
I really liked that they had candle-like dinner going, and Barney and Dad have just been talking about boobs, literally just talking about the assuming motorboats.
我真的很喜欢他们当时在办烛光晚餐，而巴尼和爸爸却一直在聊胸部，字面意思上就是在讨论“motorboat”（捂脸埋胸）的动作。
And I really liked that speed for Ted, because he's just a fucking dude, and he's a dude in his 20s still.
我真的很喜欢泰德当时的那个状态，因为他就是一个普通哥们儿，而且还是一个二十多岁的哥们儿。
He has these high-minded aspirations, but he's 29.
他有着高远的志向，但他才29岁。
You remember when I said on Sweet Taste of Liberty, I wish I had been like a touch more amused by Barney.
还记得我在《自由的甜味》那一集说过的话吗，我希望自己当时对巴尼能多表现出一点好笑的心态。
Yeah.
对。
Like I wish I had played it less like You're there here.
就像我希望当时别演得好像“你这人真烦”那种感觉。
Star shirt, eye rolling.
双手抱胸，翻白眼。
I think I was playing it a little like Steve Martin to John Candy.
我觉得我当时演得有点像史蒂夫·马丁对约翰·坎迪那样。
Yeah.
对。
In playing Strains and Automobiles.
在《飞机、火车和汽车》里那种。
Totally.
完全是。
That's kind of the energy I was playing.
我当时演的大概就是那种状态。
Yeah.
对。
And I kind of wish I had played it.
所以我有点希望当时自己能多演一点。
Like I had a little more of this couch energy, which is like, look, this guy's insane, but it does lead to great stories.
就像我有了一点这种沙发上的状态，也就是：听着，这家伙虽然疯了，但确实能带来很棒的故事。
They need each other.
他们需要彼此。
Season two ended with their recommitment ceremony to each other as wingmen.
第二季结束时，他们作为僚机重新向彼此许下了承诺。
And we've carried that into season three in this great way.
而我们在第三季中以这种很棒的方式延续了这一点。
The only thing missing for me in season three so far was really acknowledging that there's this married couple living with a single guy, looking at their future.
对我来说，目前第三季唯一缺少的就是真正去承认：这里有一对已婚夫妇和一个单身汉住在一起，并且在展望他们的未来。
And we didn't really talk about that the first few episodes.
在前几集里我们并没有真正探讨过这一点。
And I really like these past two episodes that I think Josh, you're right, it plays like a two-parter.
我真的很喜欢过去这两集，乔希，你说得对，它们拍得就像上下集一样。
This huge problem, this marital problem, this newly married couple, huge debt, buying an apartment, Lily has a secret.
这个巨大的问题，婚姻问题，这对新婚夫妇面临巨额债务、买公寓，莉莉还有一个秘密。
And by the way, are we gonna live with a single dude forever who's gonna be talking about boobs on the couch.
而且话说回来，难道我们要永远和这个在沙发上大谈胸部的单身汉住在一起吗？
Like, they have entered these different life chapters, which essentially how I met your mother at its core is married guy and his best friend is in a very committed couple, many steps ahead of him.
你看，他们已经进入了人生不同的阶段，而这基本上就是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的核心：一个已婚男人，而他的挚友处于一段非常稳定的伴侣关系中，比他领先了好几步。
And how do those two, how do those people all stay close when they're in completely different movies from each other?
当这些人身处完全不同的生活状态时，他们怎么还能保持亲密关系呢？
Like Ted and Barney on that couch, Marshall Milly at that candle at dinner 10 feet away, they're just in different chapters.
就像泰德和巴尼坐在那张沙发上一样，马歇尔和莉莉在10英尺外的烛光晚餐，他们只是处于不同的章节。
They're different life chapters.
他们处于不同的人生阶段。
Like, they're in, they're in porkies.
就像，他们处于，他们处于《猪小屁》（Porkies）里。
Yeah, you know, they're still there.
对，你知道的，他们还停留在那里。
And Marcia and Lillie are in this like adult sophisticated, like romantic comedy.
而玛西亚（Marcia）和莉莉则处于这种成人、精致、类似浪漫喜剧的状态。
Or attempting to, to do that.
或者说正试图去做到这一点。
They're attempting to move, they're trying to grow up.
他们正试图前行，他们正在努力长大。
And that's what I like so much about Lillie's secret that predates this huge, this new like mature chapter.
这就是我非常喜欢莉莉那个秘密的原因，它发生在这个庞大、全新的成熟篇章之前。
She's carrying this burden of the secret in that we, we the audience didn't know about, no one knew about, Robin didn't know about.
她一直背负着这个我们——我们观众不知道、谁都不知道、罗宾也不知道的秘密。
And we just learned this huge thing that's just like this albatross.
而我们刚刚得知了这个就像沉重包袱一样的大秘密。
And I like that.
我挺喜欢这样的。
I like watching them try to climb up into adult life and there's this thing holding them back.
我喜欢看他们努力往成年人的生活里爬，却有什么东西在拖着他们的后腿。
I really like that.
我真的很喜欢这一点。
And I like the mystery of what was this fight.
我也喜欢关于这场争吵到底是怎么回事的悬念。
I love that Ted, Ted is actually good at being an detective until he gets it entirely wrong when the fight was about.
我喜欢泰德，泰德其实很擅长当侦探，直到最后他完全猜错了他们为什么吵架。
But until that point he's quite good.
但在那之前他表现得相当不错。
I loved the, I remember, there's certain things you just remember.
我喜欢，我记得，有些事情你就是会记住。
Sometimes you remember when you guys gave me something.
有时你会记得你们俩给我某样东西的时候。
I'm switching from the first to the second person, But when you guys would give me something that I remember that little bit where she walks in on Ted shaving, and I remember the crew really delighted in that, especially like sea camera.
我从第一人称切换到第二人称，但当你们给我什么东西时，我记得那个小片段，她撞见泰德在刮胡子，我记得剧组对此感到非常高兴，尤其是摄像师。
I think Bruce and his gang really thought that was funny.
我觉得布鲁斯（Bruce）和他的团队真的觉得那很好笑。
But I thought you were shaving, well, I thought you were shaving your face.
但我还以为你在刮，好吧，我以为你在刮脸。
What was it?
那是什么？
Well, clearly I wasn't.
好吧，很显然我没有。
Yeah, yeah, clearly I wasn't.
对，对，很显然我没有。
It was so that was the hardest laugh for Rebecca sitting on the couch next to me watching that that was a really really funny Moment yeah, I really like that little case study and like single guy living with the married couple They are married now and it's and it they're just they're quick.
所以那是坐在我旁边沙发上看这一段的丽贝卡笑得最大声的一次，那真是一个非常非常有趣的时刻，对，我真的很喜欢那个小案例研究，关于单身汉和已婚夫妇住在一起，他们现在结婚了，而且这，它们只是很简练。
They're they're like quick Hirschfeld blinds.
它们就像希尔施费尔德（Hirschfeld）的速写盲画。
They're just quick.
它们非常简练。
Yes quickly sketches.
是的，快速的素描。
Yeah, they're little sketches that really put it in high relief Like this is the problem.
对，它们是那些真正把问题鲜明展现出来的小素描：这就是问题所在。
Yeah, also Also, Jordana made me rewind and freeze on my face when Marshall comes out with a peanut butter.
对，还有，当马歇尔拿着花生酱出来时，乔丹娜让我倒带并定格在我的脸上。
And she was like, that's the face you make when I say like, why did you do the, where did you put the, or whatever, like, you know, like a marital thing of like.
她当时说，这就是当我问你“你为什么做这个”、“你把它放哪了”诸如此类的话时，你脸上露出的表情，你知道的，就像那种夫妻间的对话。
The slightly busted face?
那个略显尴尬的表情？
Like a slightly busted face.
就像一个略显尴尬的表情。
That's exactly right.
完全没错。
She's like, I know they're nasty names so well.
她当时就想：我太了解这些讨厌的表情了。
She had to rewind it.
她不得不倒带重看。
But it turned out to be Lily.
但结果证明那是莉莉。
It was Lily did it anyway.
总之那是莉莉干的。
It was an effect, but it was, it was a mystery of busted face.
这是一个效果，但它是一个关于尴尬表情的谜团。
The martial speech about the real world is so funny.
马歇尔关于《真实世界》（The Real World）的演讲太搞笑了。
Yeah, not the early seasons.
对，不是指早期的那些季。
Not the early seasons when they had jobs.
不是指他们有工作的那几早期季。
I'm talking about Hawaii and Africa.
我说的是夏威夷和非洲。
I watched so many of those early real world seasons in Sotomayor.
我在索托马约尔看了好多《真实世界》的早期节目。
We were pretty religious about those.
我们对那些节目可以说是相当狂热。
So that was the bad thing for me.
所以对我来说那可真不是什么好事。
Well, how great that you had an outlet to talk about them.
好吧，能有一个宣泄口去谈论它们真是太棒了。
Yes, and add it up to something.
是的，而且还能让它发挥点作用。
Ben Lee, my songwriting friend who I had the band with Radner and Lee, he posted this thing on Instagram that made me laugh so hard where he was at Largo doing some evening and he was talking to Judd Apatow backstage about the Real Housewives franchise.
本·李（Ben Lee），我的词曲创作朋友，我曾和他一起组过Radner and Lee乐队，他在Instagram上发了一件让我笑得前仰后合的事：他在Largo参加某个晚会，在后台和贾德·阿帕图（Judd Apatow）聊起了《娇妻》（Real Housewives）系列真人秀。
And Ben like knew two of them very specifically and very well.
而且本对其中两个人了解得非常具体且深入。
And he said Judd knew all of them like perfectly.
他说杰德对所有人都了如指掌，就像完全认识他们一样。
Like he had not met a single one.
就好像他甚至没见过其中任何一个人似的。
How does he find the time?
他怎么找得出时间？
And Ben said, Ben said, I don't think I would have the time or the energy to keep up with all that.
本说，本说，我想我没有时间和精力去应付所有这些。
And Judd said, you can do it.
然后杰德说，你能做到的。
You have to just do it.
你必须得这么做。
You can find the time.
你能抽出时间的。
This is important for you.
这对你很重要。
You have the time and you can do it.
你有时间，而且你做得到。
And he said it was like this weird showbiz pep talk.
他说这就像是一场奇怪的娱乐圈励志演讲。
That's really funny.
那真的太搞笑了。
This is important.
这很重要。
You got to get honest.
你得坦诚一点。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
I really liked Barney's immediate deference to Ted.
我真的很喜欢巴尼对泰德那种立刻展现出的顺从。
Once Ted started being really confident as the detective Ted in that act three, like figuring out what this fight was, Barney just wants a strong male role model in his life.
一旦泰德在第三幕里开始表现得像个真正的侦探那样自信，比如弄清楚这场争吵是怎么回事，巴尼就渴望生活中能有个强有力的男性榜样。
And the second Ted starts being really strong and clear, Barney's like, yeah, yeah boss.
而就在泰德开始变得强势和清醒的瞬间，巴尼就变成了一副“好的，好的，老大”的态度。
And like sneering at Robin, like don't get in Ted's way, like energy, like Ted's like cracking the case.
甚至还对罗宾冷嘲热讽，摆出“别挡泰德的路”这种气势，就像泰德正在破案一样。
He's just absolutely embracing second in command.
他简直是百分之百地接受了二把手的身份。
And then you're right, in that transition, once they think Marshall Lee might be getting a divorce, Barney falls the fuck apart.
然后你说得对，在那个转折点，一当他们觉得马修和莉莉可能要离婚时，巴尼整个人彻底崩溃了。
And I thought he wanted Ted to be his strong male role model as the detective.
我还以为他只是想让泰德当他身为侦探时的强力男性榜样呢。
And then he also wants these parent figures.
结果他同时还想要这种父母般的角色。
And I guess some hope of couplehood that he gets out of Marshall and Lilly.
我猜他也从马修和莉莉身上得到了一些对伴侣关系的期许。
He crumbles so fucking hard when he had the thought of Marshall and Lilly potentially breaking up.
一想到马修和莉莉可能会分手，他竟然难过得一塌糊涂。
And I think that was so winning and charming and vulnerable that it kind of did.
我觉得那表现得太讨人喜欢、太迷人、太脆弱了，以至于它在某种程度上……
in the way you described earlier, it kind of did make it right how horrible he was to poor April Bulby earlier in the episode.
就像你刚才形容的那样，它确实在某种程度上弥补了他之前在剧集开头对可怜的阿普尔·鲍尔比那么粗暴的行为。
But I do, I think he probably did deserve a little, a little like something, a little swat, a little slap, karmically and more than he got in this one, because he was pretty straighty the way he walked out on her in the shower.
但我确实觉得，从因果报应的角度来说，他可能还是罪有应得，应该受点小小的惩罚、挨个小耳光什么的，比他在这一集里实际受到的要多，因为他在淋浴间抛下她那出确实挺混蛋的。
You know that?
你知道吗？
It was funny.
这挺搞笑的。
I didn't remember what episode it was from, but me wearing sunglasses with Barney saying there's a reason you're, or I think Barney says you, there's a reason your name is Robin.
我不记得这是出自哪一集了，不过我戴着太阳镜，巴尼说“这就是为什么你……”或者我觉得是巴尼说“你……”，有个原因让你叫罗宾。
No, Ted says it to Robin.
不，是泰德对罗宾说的。
And this one is Ted says Robin.
这一集里是泰德对罗宾说。
Yeah, there's reason you're a reason your name is Robin not that man.
对，有个原因让你叫罗宾，而不是那个名字。
That's like a pretty that That's a meme that goes around to me.
这简直是个……这算是个在网上广为流传的表情包。
I see that all the time I was like excited to get up to it the in this episode when watching this last day because I was like That's from that meme from that show That's our show.
我经常看到，前几天看这一集的时候我还挺兴奋地等着看这出，因为我想：这不就是那个剧里的表情包嘛，这就是我们的剧。
I Did not remember I you could never I would never I would lose a bet if you asked me what episode that was from I thought it was from later in the series because Ted does play detective Ted a couple times in series.
我其实不记得了，你绝对猜不到、我也绝对记不住，如果有人问我这是出自哪一集，我肯定会答不上来。我以为是剧集更后面的部分，因为泰德在剧中确实客串过好几次侦探泰德。
And I was really like, Oh shit, we're okay.
当时我真的很惊讶，哦靠，我们居然……
That's in season three.
那是在第三季。
That meme.
那个表情包。
You guys did a lot of like, um, you guys did the CSI kind of forensic, yeah, that parody held.
你们拍了很多类似……呃，你们拍了那种《CSI》风格的法证桥段，对，那个恶搞真的很到位。
Yeah, they're green.
对，它们是绿色的。
But also, I didn't know this at the time, but CSI Miami was on and David Caruso would like, he did a lot of sunglasses acting did some sunglasses work.
而且，我当时并不知道，但当时《CSI：迈阿密》正在热播，大卫·卡鲁索经常戴着太阳镜演戏，做很多墨镜戏份。
That was his thing.
那是他的标志。
And I, I have, you know, over the years, because we were at CBS events and all these things.
而且这些年来，因为我们经常参加CBS的活动以及各种场合……
A couple of those actors from CSI Miami, not David Caruso, by the way, but a couple of them said, we really love that episode.
《CSI：迈阿密》的几个演员——顺便说一句，不是大卫·卡鲁索，但其中好几个演员对我们说，他们真的很喜欢那一集。
Like, we really love that.
就像，他们真的很喜欢那个。
Yeah.
对。
When you guys kind of like parodied us a bit.
当你们那种恶搞我们的时候。
Yeah.
对。
You were, that's what it was.
原来是这样。
You were doing Caruso, but I don't even know how aware you were that that's what you were doing in the moment.
你当时在模仿卡鲁索，但我甚至不知道你在当下是否意识到自己正在这么做。
I guess we've probably shown you a tape of it.
我想我们大概给你看过录像了。
No, you either.
不，你也没有。
You were Carter had to explain it to me because I forgive me.
你……卡特得跟我解释一下，因为原谅我。
I was not a CSI Miami watcher.
我不是《犯罪现场调查：迈阿密》的观众。
But I suppose you watched every episode actually.
不过我想你其实每集都看了。
Dave Baker or someone pulled a clip for me.
戴夫·贝克或是谁帮我找了个剪辑片段。
Like someone showed me.
就像有人给我看了看。
And if you've seen one, you've seen him all, he did his trademark thing, but you did it, you nailed it.
而且你看过一集，就等于看过了全部，他做了他标志性的动作，但你做到了，你拿捏住了。
Detective Ted was excellent in this episode.
泰德探员在这集里太棒了。
It was very, that full run was so fucking funny.
真的，整段戏太TM好笑了。
And just Barney being so all in on it was just hilarious.
而且巴尼对这事儿那么投入，简直笑死人了。
He just immediately deferred to Ted.
他直接就把指挥权交给了泰德。
The Mosby boys cracked a lot of big cases.
莫斯比男孩们破过很多大案。
The case of the missing retainer, was that the one?
失踪的牙齿保持器案，是那个吗？
Yes, let me guess I was in the garbage.
是的，让我猜猜，它在垃圾桶里。
Why are you like this?
你为什么总是这样？
And Barney hates that Robin's ruining it.
而巴尼讨厌罗宾破坏气氛。
Barney really likes Detective Ted.
巴尼真的很喜欢泰德探员。
It's just such a leap.
这跨度也太大了。
I'm such a little kid.
我还像个小孩子。
Dude, you're gonna need a stronger stomach than that, Delphi.
老兄，你的承受能力可得再强一点，德尔菲。
Delphi is just film noir immediately.
德尔菲直接就是黑色电影的风格。
It was great, yeah.
太棒了，对。
But also, I mean, his lifting up the...
而且还有，我是说，他举起那个……
I mean, yeah, he's a good detective until he has the absolute wrong conclusion.
我是说，对，他是个好探员，直到他得出完全错误的结论。
He just has the wrong conclusion, But he's really close.
他只是得出了错误的结论，但他真的很接近真相。
He really, he almost threaded the needle and then not quite.
他真的很，他差点就理清头绪了，但又没完全理清。
Um, but it's a good, there's something also funny about arrogant Ted is like, I mean, certainly there's a lot of arrogant Ted is coming down the bike, but I think you guys were finding a different speed for him where he was just, just, just kind of overconfident in his, uh, yes, yeah, and smart.
呃，不过这很棒，自大版泰德也有好笑的地方，我是说，当然，接下来还会有很多自大版泰德的戏份，但我觉得你们当时在为他寻找一种不同的状态，让他显得只是，只是，只是对他的，呃，是的，没错，而且很聪明。
Well, like we talked about, uh, out of my case thing, nothing funnier than being confidently wrong.
嗯，就像我们讨论过的，呃，关于我的案子的事，没有什么比盲目自信地犯错更好笑的了。
There is nothing funnier and when Ted ends up having the right conclusion, it's funny.
没有什么比这更好笑了，当泰德最终得出正确结论时，这很有趣。
But up until that moment, he was actually really good.
但在那一刻之前，他其实表现得非常出色。
I like when Robin does pitch in one thing she noticed, and he's like, nice catch, Rook.
我喜欢罗宾插话提到她注意到的某件事时，他说：干得好，菜鸟。
You're very funny.
你太搞笑了。
You were having fun in that whole sequence.
你在整段戏里都玩得很开心。
That was a great sequence.
那段戏太棒了。
I loved it.
我太喜欢了。
I remember loving that.
我记得我当时就很喜欢。
Yeah.
对。
That was a delight.
那真是一种享受。
Like Ted doesn't have a ton in this episode, right?
就像泰德在这集里戏份不多，对吧？
He's a little bit along for these other rides.
他只是顺便参与了其他人的这些闹剧。
But I think that's such a star turn for Ted in that moment that it kind of makes up for the whole.
但我觉得对于泰德来说，那一刻是一个如此耀眼的转折点，以至于有点弥补了整个……
Yeah, so that's when you don't have a big episode, you guys would give each character one Aria.
对，所以当你的戏份不多时，你们会给每个角色安排一段“咏叹调”。
One great bit, one Aria, yes.
一个精彩的桥段，一段咏叹调，是的。
Yeah, they would just be like, they'd just get to solo for a little while to like.
对，他们就像是，可以稍微独唱一会儿，来……
And what is meme from this episode?
这集里有什么梗流传下来了吗？
Yeah.
对。
The Batman Robin line is very, right?
蝙蝠侠和罗宾的台词很有意思，对吧？
There's a couple other very memorable things from this episode.
这集里还有其他几个非常让人印象深刻的东西。
I see the dough is a triple thing, meme it a little bit too, but that moment was the big Ted moment.
我看那个关于面团的三重梗，也稍微成了一个梗，但那个时刻才是泰德的高光时刻。
I loved seeing a flashback to the reverse Mohawk cutting.
我很高兴看到当年剪反向莫霍克发型的闪回。
Yes, as his second stupidest thing, the first one was jumping off the roof as some sort of bird costume.
是的，作为他的第二蠢的事，第一件事是穿着某种鸟类服装从屋顶跳下去。
Do you know what your Diana said about Marshall and Lily regarding their real estate stuff?
你知道你的戴安娜对马修和莉莉的房产买卖有什么看法吗？
She said, I could help them.
她说，我可以帮帮他们。
And she said that because she has a side, my wife is one of those street easy Zillow lurkers.
她之所以这么说，是因为她有个爱好——我妻子就是那种会潜水 StreetEasy 和 Zillow 的人。
Like she's always, you know.
就像她总是，你知道的。
But like Carter, what are you doing?
但卡特就像是，你在干嘛？
She's like, nothing.
她说，没什么。
This is Carter street easy.
这是卡特的 StreetEasy。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
This is Carter.
这是卡特。
This is why he loves all this shit.
这就是为什么他喜欢所有这些破事。
He is such a real estate whore, that guy, he really is, he would say the same thing.
这家伙简直就是个房产控，真的，他自己也会这么说。
We have friends who, they'll put your banana on the case, because she's not looking for an apartment for us, but she loves the, it's almost like looking for your friends like we look through the stating site with me.
我们有些朋友，他们会把你的香蕉（女友/妻子）派上用场，因为她不是在为我们找公寓，但她喜欢那种感觉，这几乎就像和我们一起浏览约会网站一样，在帮朋友找。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Like I'm not looking for me, I'm looking for my friend.
就像我不是在为自己找，我是在为我朋友找。
Yeah, but she has, she knows, she knows how to look at those things and how to see.
对，但她有，她懂得，她懂得如何看这些东西，如何看出门道。
Did she lead the way, getting you guys to Fort Green to be calmer than that?
是她带头让你们搬到格林堡去的吗，好让自己过得平静点？
This was weirdly me.
这奇怪地是由我主导的。
This was where you interested?
这是……你有兴趣吗？
This was me because she didn't want to leave the neighborhood and we looked at a place kind of like a closer to downtown Brooklyn and we were looking at a rental and I told a woman, oh, we really want to stay in this neighborhood and she said, well, we have a place.
这是因为她不想离开这个街区，我们看了一个地方，有点像靠近布鲁克林市中心，我们当时在看一处出租房，我跟一个女人说，哦，我们真的很想留在这个街区，她说，嗯，我们有个地方。
No, it's exactly right.
不，完全正确。
She said, we have a place that's not a rental though, it's for sale.
她说，不过我们有个地方不是出租的，是要出售的。
And then I looked at it.
然后我去看了。
She showed it to me and I said, oh, I think that's our apartment and I showed it to her and we were the first birthday, let's see it.
她带我看了看，我说，哦，我觉得这就是我们的公寓，我把它给看了看，我们是第一批……来看看吧。
But then, anyway, we ended up getting it after some shenanigans.
不过后来，不管怎样，经过一番折腾，我们最终买下了它。
But we wrote them a song, this lovely French couple.
但我们给他们写了一首歌，这对可爱的法国夫妇。
We wrote them.
我们写给他们的。
I saw that.
我看到了。
I sent it to you.
我发给你了。
Yeah, that was amazing.
对，太棒了。
That was amazing, yeah.
那真的很棒，对。
So this is another like New York real estate.
所以这是另一个关于纽约房地产的故事。
Like you got to use everything you got.
就像你得用上你所能用的一切。
You got to use everything there.
你得用上那里的所有资源。
It is an emotional process, even for the seller because the seller was 12 or 15 bids on this place.
这是一个充满情感的过程，对卖家也是如此，因为卖家在这个地方收到了12或15个出价。
Like we had to get to the front of the line.
就像我们必须挤到队伍最前面一样。
Yeah, that's really funny.
对，那真的很好笑。
And there was something as a seller too, where you're like, especially if you had a real life there, you want to like pass it along to someone else that's going to build a nice life there.
作为卖家，也有这样一种心理，你会觉得，尤其是如果你在那里度过了真实的生活，你会想把它转交给另一个会在那里建立美好生活的人。
And look what you've done, you have this lovely home, you have this lovely child, and that is your son's first place he gets to live in the world.
看看你们做到了什么，你们有这个可爱的家，有这个可爱的孩子，那是你儿子在这个世界上生活的第一个地方。
They had three children here and the couple before us had three children here.
他们在这里生了三个孩子，我们之前的上一对夫妇也在这里生了三个孩子。
So our downstairs neighbor were like, they were like, this, that's a fertile apartment.
所以我们的楼下邻居就说，他们说，这，这是一套多产的公寓。
People move in there, people move in their single and leave with a big brood, you know.
单身的人搬进来，离开时带着一大群孩子，你知道的。
That is really funny, family band, family, it's all ends with a family band.
这真的太搞笑了，家庭乐队，家庭，最后一切都以一个家庭乐队收场。
I loved when Lily said you went to that brand name, law school, I know it makes you feel good and pretty.
我太喜欢莉莉说“你去了那个名牌法学院，我知道这让你感觉良好又漂亮”的那段了。
The guilty Lily is very funny, guilty, I really fucked up Lily is a very funny speed for having him in both of these.
满心愧疚的莉莉太搞笑了，愧疚、真的搞砸了的莉莉，对于在这两集中有她的戏份来说，是一种非常搞笑的状态。
This does feel like a two-parter.
这确实感觉像是个上下集。
I liked watching these two back-to-back.
我很喜欢连续看这两集。
We did full disclosure, we recorded two episodes, we talked about that we did we did not not that guy before this and it really plays like an hour.
我们坦诚地说，我们录了两集，我们讨论了在这之前我们没有……而它听起来真的很像一小时。
I'm surprised by how often when we do two in a row it really feels like an hour.
我很惊讶，当我们连着录两集时，感觉真的就像一小时。
I really like that about the show and there's sometimes it's a three-parter.
我真的很喜欢节目的这一点，有时它是三集的。
I'm proud of that.
我为此感到骄傲。
It was a tough sell at first.
一开始很难推销。
CBS didn't have a lot of sitcoms that did that or zero sitcoms that did that and I'm glad we were the one because it rewards that type of viewing.
CBS没有很多这样的情景喜剧，或者说零部，我很高兴我们是那个特例，因为它回报了那种观看方式。
Again, I think that's why people watch it after all these years over and over because it is Satisfying in the way that like you you follow the through line you it takes you on a ride that like it's taking you somewhere You watch three or four of them if they're the right three and four They kind of play like a little movie or certainly like a nice hour or something, and it's yeah I'm very proud of that.
再说一次，我认为这就是为什么人们在这么多年后一遍又一遍地看它，因为它有一种满足感，就像你跟随主线，它带你踏上一段旅程，带你去往某处。如果你看三四集，如果是对的三四集，它们有点像一部小电影，或者肯定像一个美好的小时左右，是的，我对此非常骄傲。
I did write a note Barney's plan is so dark Really doesn't I like what you said about his his energy shift later kind of saves it but he probably should have got the spanked a little somehow later in my camera.
我确实记了个笔记，巴尼的计划太黑暗了。我喜欢你说的关于他后来的能量转变在某种程度上拯救了这一点，但他后来可能还是应该挨点小打，不知怎么的，以我的视角。
I like the momentous step into adulthood, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, right?
我喜欢那个迈向成年之的重要步伐，咕嘟、咕嘟、咕嘟、咕嘟、咕嘟，对吧？
To me, that one line is kind of like, A, this episode, but all of how I met your mother, right?
对我来说，那句台词有点像，A，这一集，但也是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的全部，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
They're taking a momentous step into adulthood.
他们正在迈出走向成年重要的一步。
And they're also like...
而且他们还……
And also chug.
还有咕嘟。
Chug.
咕嘟。
Yeah.
对。
That's the series in a nutshell, right there.
这就是整部剧的精髓所在。
That's certainly the early part of the series in a chug.
这绝对是剧集早期的咕嘟。
The comically large bottle of champagne was so many bars have that and you always wonder what's going on with that thing is anyone ever going to open that.
那个滑稽的大瓶香槟，很多酒吧都有那个，你总是好奇那东西到底是怎么回事，有没有人会打开它。
I love that Wendy says, I think there was a goldfish in there at one point when you made the sale quit selling.
我喜欢温迪说的那句，我想有一次里面有条金鱼，当时你们在说促销，别再推销了。
Do you have any made the sale quit selling?
你们有什么“促销，别再推销了”的吗？
I love that line.
我喜欢那句台词。
And Marshall's drinking it.
而且马歇尔在喝它。
I think the next day it's just been open in the bar and he's just drinking it again.
我想第二天它就一直在酒吧里开着，然后他又在喝它了。
And we could just round things out, Josh, if you check out your text, Jordana has answered the question.
为了圆满结束，乔斯，如果你看一下你的短信，乔丹娜已经回答了那个问题。
Oh my.
哦，天哪。
brother's stepdad and named Crane Davis and she says they named it or he says actually they named it that way to create a name no yuppie would ever want to move into in the status obsessed 1980s down under the Manhattan Bridge overpass.
兄弟的继父，名叫克兰·戴维斯，她说他们这样命名，或者其实是他说的，他们这样命名是为了在奉行地位至上的1980年代、在曼哈顿大桥立交桥下，创造一个没有任何雅皮士会想搬进来的名字。
They were fighting the developers.
他们在对抗开发商。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
对。
That's great.
太棒了。
Okay.
好吧。
So I don't know where the fuck I was and I like felt like I never heard that.
所以我不知道我特么刚才说到哪了，我觉得我好像从没听过这个。
No, it was like in my 30s.
不，那大概是我30多岁的时候。
Yeah.
对。
Okay.
好吧。
That's cool.
这很酷。
That's cool to know.
知道这个很酷。
But yeah, a great, a great episode and really fun.
不过是的，很棒的一集，真的很有趣。
And I love the reveal of the name at the end.
而且我很喜欢最后揭晓名字的环节。
Like, I also really liked that when the letters came together that Lillian Marshall look up at the letters on the screen.
比如，我也很喜欢当字母组合在一起时，莉莉和马歇尔抬头看着屏幕上的字母。
They can see the word for me.
他们可以看到那个词正在……
They can see them forming the word and we're seeing the word.
他们能看到它们组成这个词，而我们也在看着这个词。
It's very sad.
这非常悲伤。
That's a great, that's one of my favorite tags.
这是一个很棒的，这是我最喜欢的片尾小彩蛋之一。
Well, remember this, we might talk about tags at some point with the office ladies.
好吧，记住这个，我们以后可能会在《办公室女士》节目里聊聊片尾彩蛋。
That little tag, that little final beat is so funny.
那个小彩蛋，那个最后的小节拍太搞笑了。
I like take that note.
我记下这个笔记。
Well, that's a good tag because we made it up to some of the office ladies.
好吧，这是个不错的彩蛋，因为我们向《办公室女士》的一些人提及过。
We're talking about favorite tags.
我们在讨论最喜欢的彩蛋。
I really like this one.
我真的很喜欢这个。
It's funny and it sets up a real problem.
它很有趣，并且设定了一个真实的问题。
You want to tune in next week to be like, Oh shit, they just sunk beyond their life savings into a place that smells horrible.
你会想在下周继续收看，心想：靠，他们刚刚把毕生积蓄全砸在了一个闻起来臭气熏天的地方。
And all right, please write into if you're a New Yorker and you walk by, I want to say somewhere in the upper 40s by the West Side Highway.
还有，好了，如果你是个纽约人，而且你路过，我想说大概在西区公路附近的40多街高段。
There's a big, it is called a stupid treatment plan.
有一个大型的，它被称为一个愚蠢的处理计划。
It is labeled as a stupid treatment plan.
它被标记为一个愚蠢的处理计划。
It doesn't always stink, but certain days, it really is always a cheapo right there.
它并不总是发臭，但在某些日子里，那里真的总是一个廉价货。
Right to me and let me know if you've experienced that.
写信告诉我你是否经历过这种事。
It's a thing.
这是个客观存在的现象。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
We are wrapping up this week's episode with our sea blood.
我们要用我们的“海之血”来结束本周的节目。
Sea blood.
海之血。
I don't know why, but it does feel natural.
我不知道为什么，但它确实感觉很自然。
Let's just go with it.
那就顺其自然吧。
It's just getting weirder.
这越来越诡异了。
This is where we read a letter from you, one of our listeners and a lover of how I met your mother, if you would like to send us a voice note or a written letter about what this show means to you, how I met your mother, go to how we madeyourmother.com, hwmym.com, go to contact, follow the instructions and here is this week's letter.
在这里，我们要读一封来自你们的信，来自我们的一位听众、《老爸老妈浪漫史》的铁粉。如果你想给我们发一段语音留言或一封信，聊聊这部剧对你意味着什么，《老爸老妈浪漫史》，请访问 howwemakeyourmother.com，hwmym.com，点击联系，按照说明操作，以下是本周的信件。
Dear Josh, Craig, and Alec, it's nice that everyone includes you, Alec.
亲爱的乔斯、克雷格和亚历克，大家把亚历克也算进去真好。
I always, I enjoy it.
我一直，我很享受。
I know, it's nice, you're in it, you're part of it.
我知道，这很好，你在里面，你是其中的一部分。
My name is Jessica, I'm a fellow Hollywood writer who, like so many of your viewers, has remained such a fan of this show because of how beautifully it treats the concept of a chosen family.
我叫杰西卡，我也是个好莱坞编剧，和你们的许多观众一样，我一直是这部剧的超级粉丝，因为这部剧对“选择的家庭”这一概念的处理是如此优美。
Like Ted and Marshall, I met my best friend, Hannah, in our dorm room.
就像特德和马歇尔一样，我在宿舍里遇到了我最好的朋友汉娜。
It was the fall of 2005, coincidentally, the same year, him, him premiered, and less than a year later, I met the man I would eventually marry.
那是2005年秋天，巧合的是，这也是《老妈》首播的同一年，不到一年后，我遇到了我最终要嫁的那个男人。
Funnily enough, his name is Robin.
说来也巧，他的名字叫罗宾。
Shortly after we finished college, Hannah reconnected with a childhood friend of hers named Christa, and the three of us immediately formed a bond.
我们大学毕业后不久，汉娜和她童年的一位朋友克里斯塔重新取得了联系，我们三个人立刻建立起了紧密的羁绊。
All of us were only children, and we grew to form a sisterhood.
我们都是独生女，我们渐渐形成了一种姐妹情谊。
Early on, I introduced them to himium, and it quickly became a reason for us to frequently get together, have dinner, ask philosophical questions such as, is this man a rabbit or a duck?
早期，我向她们安利了《老妈》，它很快成了我们经常聚在一起、吃晚饭、问出一些哲学问题的理由，比如，这个男人是兔子还是鸭子？
And who would woo, and even set up a March Madness bracket a friend when she started using gating apps, a failed experiment, since the very first guy on the list was the guy she married.
谁会去追求？甚至当一个朋友开始使用约会软件时，还为她建立了一个疯狂三月对阵表，一个失败的实验，因为列表上的第一个男人就是她嫁的那个男人。
We were inseparable for the precious years we all lived near each other in Denver, but in 2014 I took a big leap and moved to L.A.
在我们都住在丹佛附近的宝贵岁月里，我们形影不离，但在2014年，我迈出了一大步，搬到了洛杉矶，以进一步追求我的娱乐行业职业生涯。
to further pursue my career in entertainment.
就像特德一样，我有一个计划，努力工作几年，建立好人脉，充实简历，然后搬回家买下完美的房子，再次和我的朋友们住得很近。
Much like Ted, I had a plan, work hard for a few years, make good connections, build up that resume, then move back home to buy the perfect house and live near my friends again.
但正如特德多次学到的那样，宇宙并不是按我们的计划运转的。
as Ted learned many times the universe doesn't work according to our plans.
我在洛杉矶从事独立电影工作，并磨练我作为电视编剧的手艺，长达11年，历经几次巨大成功的浪潮和更多失败的时刻。
I stayed in LA working in an independent film and honing my craft as a TV writer for 11 years, writing the waves of several big moments of success and many more moments of failure.
在此期间，我们中有两人结婚了，一人有了两个可爱的孩子，正如特德的孩子们称呼他的朋友那样，他们叫我杰西阿姨。
In the meantime, two of us got married and one had two wonderful children who, as Ted's children refer to his friends, call me Aunt Jesse.
作为独生子女，这是一个我从未期望听到的称呼。
As an only child, it's a title I had never expected to hear.
经历了这一切，《老妈》一直是一个持久的存在，从互相发短信庆祝“快乐鞭打节”，或者在每个4月20日互相发送马歇尔吃三明治的表情包。
Through it all, him-yam was a constant presence from texting each other happy-slapsgiving or sending each other gifts of Marshall eating a sandwich every 420.
毕竟我们来自科罗拉多州。
We are from Colorado, after all, to watching a hungover on the couch together the morning after my husband's 40th birthday.
再到在我丈夫40岁生日的第二天早上，宿醉着一起窝在沙发上观看。
Unlike Lily and Marshall, our marriage didn't ultimately make it.
不同于莉莉和马歇尔，我们的婚姻最终没能维持下去。
And as I told the girls, the moment I knew we had to throw in the towel, I actually heard the sound of glass breaking.
正如我对女孩们所说的那样，在我知道我们不得不认输的那一刻，我真的听到了玻璃碎裂的声音。
In 2025, the industry collapsed, had me wondering what else was out there.
在2025年，行业崩溃了，这让我开始琢磨外面还有什么。
I learned that a university in England was offering a master's degree in magic and occult science.
我得知英国的一所大学正在提供魔法和神秘科学的硕士学位。
And I knew I had to go.
我知道我必须去。
When I told my niece, I was basically going to grown up Hogwarts.
当我告诉我的侄女，我基本上是要去成年人的霍格沃茨时。
She was thrilled, but astutely asked, won't that make it harder for you to come visit?
她很兴奋，但也精明地问：那不是会让你更难来看我吗？
It's been an amazing ride out here in England and I intend to stay in London for the foreseeable future, though it is indeed difficult to be farther away from my chosen family.
我在英国的这段经历简直棒极了，我打算在可预见的未来留在伦敦，尽管离我选择的家庭更远确实很不容易。
What a blessing it has been to have discovered this podcast.
能发现这个播客，真的是一种福气。
Now we're all rewatching the show for the five thousandth time rehashing our favorite episodes and learning more about the BTS stories that made the show so special.
现在我们都在第五千次重温这部剧，重温我们最喜欢的剧集，并更多地了解让这部剧如此特别的幕后故事。
As a fellow writer and producer, I admit, that's my favorite part.
作为同行的编剧和制片人，我承认，这是我最喜欢的部分。
On that note, I'm extremely grateful to Craig and Carter for not caving to the network when they tried to make you ditch the serialized nature of the storylines.
顺便说一句，我非常感谢克雷格和卡特，感谢他们在电视网试图让你们放弃剧情连载性质时没有向他们妥协。
The first episode I ever watched was drumroll, please.
我看的第一集是，请敲鼓。
And even though I hadn't seen the previous episode about the wedding invitation and didn't know these characters, it was the unusual storytelling and their sibling-like banter that got me on the hook.
尽管我之前没看过关于婚礼请贴的那集，也不认识这些角色，但正是这种独特的叙事方式和他们兄妹般的逗趣互怼，让我彻底入坑了。
Thank you for trusting your gut and writing the show you wanted to write.
感谢你坚持内心，写出了你想创作的节目。
authenticity is what made your viewers feel so connected to this fun and beautiful world.
正是这种真实感，让观众对这个有趣而美好的世界产生了强烈的共鸣。
I don't know what will be in store for me while living in London, but there are two things I know for sure.
我不知道在伦敦生活期间会有什么在等着我，但我有两件事是确定的。
I'll always have my sisters, and it's going to be legend.
我永远都有我的姐妹们，而且这将会是传奇般的。
Wait for it, Derry, Jessica.
拭目以待吧，德里、杰西卡。
That's great.
太棒了。
I love that there's something magic about this letter coming because we're just talking about Harry Potter and Hogwarts and Derry Potter and Derry on Allie and like the magic of New York.
我很喜欢这封信的到来带有一种魔力，因为我们刚才还在聊哈利·波特、霍格沃茨、“德里·波特”、艾莉的德里，还有纽约的魔力。
It makes me want to hear more from like fans in London of like, like, what are those weird little, like, mythological and other fans in London?
这让我想听听更多伦敦粉丝的想法，比如，那些奇怪的、小小的、带点神话色彩的伦敦粉丝都在想什么？
I'm going to be doing a play in London this summer.
今年夏天我将在伦敦出演一部话剧。
Fuck yeah.
太棒了。
It's called Hit Machine at the Soho Theater.
它叫《命中注定》（Hit Machine），在苏荷剧院上演。
Basically, it's July through like mid-August.
基本上是从7月一直演到8月中旬左右。
Check it out, it's a great play by John Karen, Ben Harper's doing the music.
大家去看看吧，这是约翰·卡伦（John Karen）写的一部非常棒的话剧，音乐是本·哈珀（Ben Harper）做的。
It's a really cool, so bringing the fam over to London this summer, I'm really excited about it.
真的很酷，所以今年夏天我要把家人带到伦敦去，我对此感到非常兴奋。
And maybe I'll meet some people who are into the magic and occult sciences.
也许我会遇到一些对魔法和神秘学感兴趣的人。
Go see it, go see the show, Jessica.
去看看吧，去看这场演出，杰西卡。
You're part of the pod now.
你现在也是播客的一员了。
We've read your letter, you go support Josh, come say hi.
我们读了你的信，你得去支持乔什，去跟他说个嗨。
That was an awesome letter.
那是一封太棒的信。
Thank you for, I love how that letter covered this like epic scope of her life.
谢谢你，我特别喜欢那封信展现了她人生的宏大格局。
Like just shared this huge kind of portrait of very hymium style.
就像是以“老爸老妈浪漫史”的风格，分享了这样一幅宏大的画卷。
Like here's what my life has been ending in this completely unexpected new chapter that is so adventurous and weird.
这就是我的人生经历，而现在它迎来了这样一个充满冒险又古怪的、完全意想不到的新篇章。
I'm sure Jessica herself couldn't have predicted that that's where it was all leading to.
我相信杰西卡自己也绝对预测不到事情会发展到这一步。
It's great.
这太棒了。
So update us.
所以随时给我们更新情况。
and let us know how the magic of it all works out.
让我们知道这一切的魔力是如何发挥作用的。
That's a great story.
真是个精彩的故事。
Thanks for sharing it.
谢谢你分享它。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请给我装备吧。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪过都可以被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《如何与你的母亲相遇》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
本节目由 Office Ladies Network 和 Audacy 呈献并发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本节目的执行制片人还包括珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。
And the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作和剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Madica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马迪卡（Doug Madica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
And our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Catherine Grove.
我们的Z世代大师、数字内容制作人是艾米莉·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg），副制片人是凯瑟琳·格罗夫（Catherine Grove）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美术设计由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）完成。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
这真的对扩大节目影响非常有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萨姆·西博尔德（Sam Theobold）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
欢迎在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大图书销售点购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《事情不是那样的》（That's Not How It Happened），并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他的其他出版作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substep.
您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Father Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
想要了解如何为本节目筹集先天性心脏病研究资金的持续公益活动贡献力量。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上会跳舞的。
real question it just hit me am I in love with you or just New York City
真正的疑问刚刚击中了我的心：我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？